Tim Ferriss: Jake Muise. This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of The Tim Ferriss
Show, where it is my job to interview friends,
foes, everyone in between, but the common
thread is world-class performance, and the
attempt is always to dig, to excavate, to
deconstruct the lessons, thought, frameworks,
and so on, that you can apply or test or simply
ponder in your own lives.
My guest today is a friend, Jake Muise. Jake
Muise is CEO at Maui Nui Venison, a company
he co-founded in 2017 that works to balance
invasive axis deer populations on the island
of Maui. Channeling that management into incredible
nutrient dense food. Maui Nui was selected
for Fast Company's "Top 10 Most Innovative
Companies in Agriculture of 2023," and its
venison has been served in top restaurants
across the country, including Alinea, which
featured very heavily in The 4-Hour Chef.
It was a big section entirely because it's
so impressive. The French Laundry and Saison,
where I just mentioned. I was one of the very
first investors when it was a popup with 12
seats, something like that. Josh Skenes, everybody
should check him out as well.
Prior to Maui Nui, Jake was executive director
of the Axis Deer Institute for 12 years. Part
of a two-decades-long project focused on axis
deer in their long-term management in Hawai’i.
You can find them at Maui Nui, I'll spell
that out for folks, M-A-U-I N-U-I venison.com,
and you can find them on Instagram, Twitter,
et cetera, @MauiNuiVenison. I'm shocked those
handles were available.
I think we will start where all good stories
start, and that's with lava.
Jake Muise: Oh, wow.
Tim Ferriss: Fast-moving lava.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm going to use that as the
cue and I'm going to let you run with it,
but let's begin with that.
Jake Muise: Thank you so much for having me.
Tim Ferriss: Well, absolutely. It's good to
see you.
Jake Muise: We're going to have a blast. Lava,
so in 2018, a fissure started erupting on
the East Rift Zone on the Big Island. It was
an area that was a lava zone previously, but
had since been built over. So lots of homes.
There was this beautiful area called Kapoho,
which had amazing hot pools and tide pools
and, well, it's now gone, unfortunately.
So anyway, fissure 8 starts erupting; it splits
into two, and it basically cuts off a several
thousand acre area homes, people, and this
lava flow is moving very quickly, 20 miles
an hour. So within a 24-hour period is about
three miles up the coast. It's moving slower
at the front, but essentially cuts off this
entire area. State and Feds arrive right away.
They start helicoptering people and different
people out, people, plants, pets, whatever
people are holding dear.
Then a cattle rancher had been cut off, and
there were still 50-plus animals left between
these two flows. You can imagine it looked
like Mordor on the ground. Sulfur was terrible.
There was lava bonds. The fissure was constantly
spewing at about 100 to 200 feet.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, my God.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So I think the math —
Tim Ferriss: It's not a simmer.
Jake Muise: No, I think they said it was 26,000
cubic meters of lava per minute. It was absurd.
It was like one of the fastest moving flows
they'd ever seen. So anyway, a rancher did
his best job to get the majority of his cows
out, but there are 50-plus animals trapped
between these two lava flows.
Tim Ferriss: That's when you saw the Bat Signal
in the sky.
Jake Muise: Well, kind of. We had happened
about a year ago to develop the first of its
kind live capture net system that with a helicopter,
you can essentially pick up cows live and
get them out of there. So if you can imagine
a cone-shaped net with a 20-foot diameter
frame on the bottom, and it's hanging from
a hundred foot line below a helicopter. So
a helicopter's moving, and this net is flowing
back and forth, and you place the net over
the cow, and then there's a switch at the
top of the cone and there's two lines.
Then, as the animal tries to move outside,
you let the first switch go at the top of
the cone and the net basically falls on top
of it. Then you just pick up the frame and
it's essentially sitting in a big bag evenly
distributed. Then you fly it out and you put
this bag down and you put the frame over it
and it just stands up and walks away.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. So the frame is basically
a rectangle or a square?
Jake Muise: It's an octagon. Yeah. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Octagon.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, got it.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So federal, PETA, everybody
gets ahold of us and says like, "We need to
get these cows out of here." And we were —
Tim Ferriss: That's because it was known,
at least to some subset of folks, that you
developed this live capture system.
Jake Muise: We were previously using it to
try and get cows out of high elevation critical
watershed areas where they were causing extensive
damage. So they get ahold of us. They run
us through what they want us to do. Of course,
I had to sit down on the team and say like,
"Do you want to try and rescue cows over a
20 mile per hour lava flow?" I think one of
the guys turned over and he is like, "We would
get to be a lava cowboy," and I was like,
"Oh, man. Come on, who's going to say no to
that one?" Ended up doing our due diligence.
It was pretty safe to do.
But long story short. We got them all out.
But the first couple of days were so intense
and the very first cow, so we're driving out
there in the morning, it literally looks like
Mordor, the flow is creating its own weather
system. It's raining, it's dark. It's a two-mile
flow. So it's lighting up the entire area
in dark red, and you're driving towards it
and you're thinking like, "Oh," and you're
passing all these national guards and you're
just like, "This doesn't seem a great idea,"
on your way out.
We get all loaded up in the morning. The head
of PETA's there. It's this huge thing. There
had been so much loss already. They had lost
that entire community, hundreds of homes gone,
and there had been so much loss. The community
was starting to gather around this idea of,
"These things that were left behind, we could
actually get them." Get there in the morning.
We get all set up, get dialed in with the
pilot. He had actually never done it before,
but it was the only helicopter big enough
that we could pick up those particular cows.
Name's Calvin Dorn. He's just an absolute
legend.
So we fly out first thing in the morning heading
towards Fissure 8. It's fountaining, 200 feet
in the air. There's lava bombs that look like
they're going at the height of the helicopter.
The cows are trapped right underneath it.
There's video. This we can put it in the show
notes.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, man.
Jake Muise: — for people. It's crazy. He
goes to pick up the first cow, grabs the first
cow, does it all right. Then he goes to lift
and he's like, "Oh, this might be too heavy."
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no.
Jake Muise: I have my sulfur dioxide. I have
my monitors on. We're not supposed to get
on the ground. The net is attached to the
helicopter, and he is like, "What do we do?"
I was like, "Well, give it another tug. See
if you can get it off the ground." So he gives
it another tug and he gets it a little bit
off the ground, and I'm like, "Okay, can we
head downhill and you can get some elevation?"
He's like, "Here's what we're going to do.
We're going to use the heat from the lava
flow to give us a boost."
Tim Ferriss: Ride the thermals.
Jake Muise: "We're going to ride the thermals
up with this cow underneath us, and it should
give us a big enough boost. We'll have enough
elevation and then we'll be able to get down
to the corral system."
Tim Ferriss: It's crazy enough that it just
might work.
I'm thinking, I mean, you don't really have
a choice. You're like, "Sure, let's try that."
So he gets this cow off the ground and he's
moving at a good speed. And we're picking
up a little elevation, and I can see the lava
flow coming at 500 yards, 400 yards, 300 yards,
and we hit the flow and it's like somebody
kicked us in the nuts. We just went straight
up in the air. There was so much heat coming
off the flow. I looked down to see what was
happening to the cow, because the cow was
a hundred feet lower than us, and this cow
swings out, and then as it passes over the
top of the flow, all we see is just smoke.
Oh, no.
Jake Muise: I thought like, "The head of PETA
is sitting down here."
Tim Ferriss: Watching my cow get vaporized.
Jake Muise: "I'm going to jail. Something
terrible's going to happen to us. This thing
is over." We gain elevation and we start to
come out over the flow, and I'm looking down.
I'm like, "Oh, God." I had forgotten that
it was pouring rain and it was soaked and
all of that water, it just instantly vaporized.
It looked like the whole thing was essentially
on fire for a second. So we come out and I
see all of the water vapor clear, and I'm
like, "Oh, thank God." Come down, land, that
animal gets out, walks away, happy as can
be. Then I think we've got seven or eight
more that day before they shut us down and
got a little crazy, and we ended up getting
all 50 animals out of that place. Happened
to be one of the most intense moments of my
life. Certainly, maybe not the most dangerous,
but I thought we were in a lot of trouble
for that one.
But it was just such a viscerally intense
scenario. You have these lava bombs going
off and these two flows, and but a really
cool experience in that community. There was
this celebration when everything for months
had been just — a lot of loss.
Tim Ferriss: So let's set the stage a bit
by talking about the history of Hawai’i.
Maybe we could start for a second just with
the name Maui Nui. What does Maui Nui mean?
Because even people who live in the Lower
48 or continental US, many people have not
been to Hawai’i, and certainly people overseas,
many of them will not have been to Hawai’i.
But what does Maui Nui refer to?
Jake Muise: So Maui Nui refers to the three
islands of Maui, Molokaʻi, and Lānaʻi.
And epochs ago, they used to be joined. There
used to be one giant island.
Tim Ferriss: It's like the Pangea of Hawai’i.
Jake Muise: Yeah, and you can see it when
you look at topo maps or Google Earth, you
can see they used to be joined. So that's
when we were deciding on a name. We didn't
know where management might take us, but axis
deer are located on those three islands. So
we landed at Maui Nui as kind of the name.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Nui, is it fair to say, a suffix
that is used, or maybe it's just the order
of kind of noun and adjective, but big?
Jake Muise: Yes, sir. Good job.
Tim Ferriss: So you can say "Mahalo nui,"
like, "Thanks a lot," right?
Jake Muise: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Also for people, this may be
a way to get into the history also, because
we were chatting a little bit about it.
Jake Muise: Yeah. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I've been spending more time
in New Zealand and I'm fascinated by Māori
culture, and there is a very close relationship
between what we're talking about and the culture
in New Zealand. Could you speak to that a
bit?
Jake Muise: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: Then after that, and you can
tie this in however you'd like, but speak
to sort of the agriculture of pre-colonized
Hawai’i.
Jake Muise: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: So I'm going to speak to this
as best I can.
Tim Ferriss: Right. You're going to have to
have. Actually let's hit pause for a quick
second, and because I think it's worth mentioning
up front. So a company co-founded in 2017,
who is your co-founder?
Jake Muise: My extraordinary wife, Ku'ulani.
Tim Ferriss: She's amazing.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Can you say a little bit about
Ku'u for a second, Ku'ulani?
Jake Muise: Sure. I mean, first and foremost,
a mother of three amazing children. A brilliant
person all around. Funny, smart, beautiful.
But she is a genealogist and a bit of a historian,
and she guides a lot of culture within what
we do. But she has such an in-depth understanding
of our place. She'd be somebody amazing to
have on if you ever wanted to really dig in.
But she's just this anchor for me personally
and professionally to how we should be operating
in this place.
Tim Ferriss: How long has her family been
in Hawai’i?
Jake Muise: Well, she'll tell you forever.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. She also, if I'm remembering
correctly, looks at old microfiche newspapers
and sort of excavates and translates.
Jake Muise: So post-Western contact when they
didn't have a written language prior to, but
post-Western contact, they became the most
literate society in a matter of 50 years.
I think 93 to 94 percent of the entire population
could read and write. In doing so, they created
hundreds and hundreds of newspapers that she
shows me newspapers where there's a picture
of a drawn picture of a zebra, like, "Oh,
this thing is from Africa." It was extraordinary,
the level of information that they had. I
think they were also in understanding their
place post-Western contact and how quickly
their populations were declining. They were
using it as this historical record.
So they were just writing everything down.
So what she helps to do is only two percent
of those newspapers have been translated.
98 percent of what could be their culture
is sitting in these newspapers ready to be
discovered, and it's just a treasure hunt
for her, every time she looks. She comes out
and it's just like her eyes are giant, and
she's like, "I found a new name for this rain."
She's going to write an amazing book one day.
Tim Ferriss: Also, I mean, she's very much
multi-hyphenate polymath because she's also
an incredible designer. Really incredibly
good and gifted. I hesitate to say gifted,
she is gifted, but that maybe sounds like
it minimizes the hard work and dedication
required to get good at it, and an incredible
writer also on top of that. So I wanted to
mention that because that underscores the
connection that she has and that you as a
family feel with the land. So I wanted to
just mention that up front and then we can
go back to the pre-colonial agriculture and
the tie between New Zealand.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So I think you could define
this culture like literal geniuses. They were
able to navigate all of the Pacific Ocean
with extraordinary accuracy and directly speaking
about Aotearoa. So Aotearoa was settled from
Hawai’i.
Tim Ferriss: For people who don't know the
matching, so Aotearoa is the Māori word for
what is also known as New Zealand.
Jake Muise: New Zealand. Yeah. They kept such
amazing records of their voyages. My brother-in-law
got to spend a whole bunch of time there with
Māori in different communities. They have
the actual boats, the canoes that were settled
from Hawai’i. They know the lineage of who
came on the boat, and they know where the
boats are. They have them hidden, and they
know where the boats are, and that's how strongly
they can connect their ties back to Hawai’i.
You just have to imagine that somebody that
could navigate the Pacific with that much
ease and accuracy, and it's extraordinary
to hear these stories. They're on the most
isolated land mass on the planet with the
most finite resources, and so they developed,
as far as I know, some of the most ingenious
agricultural systems I've ever heard of. Great
example, they're called the Kohala Field Systems.
They had 500 miles of what looked like from
the air swelled permaculture lines, and they
used 273 different varieties of sweet potato
to produce — oh, I just remember, they're
producing now yields 60 percent better than
current sweet potato yields. You have to imagine
pre-Western contact, there were up to a million
people in the Hawaiian Islands.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Jake Muise: There's only 1.4 million people
now. So they had a million people on the most
isolated land on the planet, and they were
feeding an extraordinary population with extremely
finite resources and somehow were able to
maintain all of the biodiversity that I think
they only know of a couple small species like
a flightless bird that was just too easy to
eat. They maintained extraordinary biodiversity,
which just really points to how connected
to that place where they had these amazing,
they call them Loko iʻa, but they were fish
ponds.
So I don't know if you remember when you were
there, but there's these huge rock walls that
come out into the ocean, near shore. Some
of them are like 600 acres, and they had these
amazing aquaculture systems where they were
able to harvest fish constantly. They said
at peak performance, there were 500-plus fish
ponds across the Hawaiian Islands producing
three million pounds of fish. That's like,
apart from what they were also catching outside
of those ponds as well. I think actually,
innovation is culture in that place, and she
continues to point me back to like, "I don't
know, we're going to figure this out. We're
a part of this place. We're going to figure
out how to find balance in these places."
They just had some amazing, both agriculture
system, but also economics and social systems.
They had a particular system called an Ahupua'a
system, and it was mountain-to-ocean land
segregations that entire communities lived
in and managed, and they were managed as these
individual land segments. The entire system
was built from top to bottom to protect water.
So every feature of that system, how the food
was grown, how it entered the water, everything
was built to maintain good clean water.
Tim Ferriss: So let's segue from that to axis
deer. What on Earth are axis deer, number
one, what is the history of their presence
in Hawai’i? Why did they end up there? Then
I have follow-up questions that relate to
water.
Jake Muise: So in 1868, then, Kamehameha IV
was given this gift and —
Tim Ferriss: Who was the leader at the time.
Jake Muise: Then-ruler of the Hawaiian Islands.
Tim Ferriss: The Hawaiian Islands.
Jake Muise: Came from India down the upper
Ganges to Hong Kong. She helped translate
the story, my wife did, Ku'u.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: Then they were moved from O'ahu
where they landed, and they were moved to
the small island of Molokaʻi, only 40 miles
long, 10 miles wide, and then a kapu, which
is a restriction, was placed on them for about
15 to 20 years. And is —
Tim Ferriss: What does that mean?
Jake Muise: A kapu is nobody was allowed to
hunt them or touch them.
Tim Ferriss: And how many deer?
Jake Muise: Seven.
Tim Ferriss: Seven.
Jake Muise: Yeah. As early as 1898, there's
literature that says they hired sharpshooters
from California — well, that was 1902. They
brought sharpshooters in from California because
there was already six to 7,000 of them. What's
really unique about axis deer is they're one
of the only deer species in the world that
can breed year-round. So most other deer species
will cast their antlers. Their antlers fall
off through the year. When that happens, their
testosterone levels drop significantly and
their sperm is no longer valuable.
So axis deer are one of the only deer species
in the world that sperm stays viable year-round.
So it doesn't matter if a doe is missed in
oestrus. The current math that we have is
they are like 94 to 95 percent of them are
either lactating or pregnant year round. So
they just introduced an extraordinarily verile
species and have had profound impacts with
that type of growth rate.
Tim Ferriss: So if we then flash forward to
roughly 10 years ago or 12 years ago, what
did the situation look like in Hawai’i with
respect to axis deer, which have no natural
predators on that land mass?
Jake Muise: Yeah, on Molokaʻi.
Tim Ferriss: In India, they certainly did.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So no natural predators,
like the capability to breed year-round, extraordinary
food sources, and being able to move up and
down elevation to find what they need. So
on the island of Molokaʻi where they were
introduced, they're now at a — sustainable
capacity is the wrong word, but their population
is only going up and down with available feed
every year. What's happening is they just
have massive die-offs, and it was actually
—
Tim Ferriss: What do the numbers look like?
Jake Muise: 70,000 and there's only 7,000
people.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Jake Muise: Yeah. It's actually one of the
reasons I got so interested in the subject
as a whole is I think it was my second year
in college and introduced this amazing family,
and I was there hunting, trying to fill up
my freezer for college because I was broke.
I was there during a die-off. I remember coming
around this corner and seeing 40 to 50 animals
just lying there, lethargic, essentially dying
of malnutrition, and it was an animal that
was introduced to me as something to love,
and it was precious. For the people of Molokaʻi,
it was this amazing food source. But that's
the only way they're currently balancing populations
is just this really sad thing that happens
every —
Tim Ferriss: Overpopulation famine, and then
it corrects.
Jake Muise: Yeah, and then it corrects. They
lose about a third of the population every
seven to 10 years.
Tim Ferriss: What is the impact on the various
islands ecologically? Because I remember watching
first time, this video that you guys produced
in collaboration with a number of other folks
and hearing voiceover, I think it was with
people talking about flying over certain areas
and saying, "Oh, wow, we didn't know the wildfire
reached this far," and the answer was, "That's
not wildfire."
Jake Muise: Yeah, because they can eat so
closely to the ground, and they're in such
large numbers, there can be herds of four
to 5,000. They're able to denude landscapes
in days. The real issue with that is when
they do that in our watershed areas or high
elevation areas, those trees developed over
epochs thousands and thousands of years to
capture water. What ends up happening is when
we have some data from this, from a recent
study, those watersheds are operating at 50
percent of their previous capacity.
Tim Ferriss: So I guess there are multiple
issues at the consequences of that, right?
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: One is you're just not capturing
water, which is important if you're in the
middle of the ocean, unless you have a massive
desalination program. You need the rainwater.
What is the effect now that has on runoff?
Jake Muise: Yeah. So when you think about
it from a — they call it Mauka to Makai,
like mountain-to-ocean impact. What all of
that denuded landscape is anytime we get any
type of significant rain, even a decent medium
rain these days, it's pulling all of that
topsoil, which took thousands of years to
make, and then it's depositing it on our reefs.
What ends up happening is they're smothering
both new and old coral and the coral die.
So there's huge tracks of what used to be
some of the most pristine reefs in the world
that are now dead, and that also then impacts
nearshore fisheries.
So we just had this amazing conversation about
producing millions of pounds of fish pre-Western
contact, and now a lot of those reef systems
being very negatively impacted by that sediment
deposit from runoff. Then when you look back
up slope, mid-range, call it 1,000 to 6,000
feet, is where our food systems in are. So
it's where cattle ranchers operates, and farmers
and coffee and all of these different, really
important — for as a function of food security,
all these amazing foods that we're trying
to grow there. You can't grow them unless
you have a 10-foot fence at $45 a foot, and
even then, like —
Tim Ferriss: $45 a foot.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That's not cheap.
Jake Muise: No. So they are also having a
severe impact on our food system. So ecosystems,
food systems, nearshore, fisheries, and reefs,
it is a compounding conversation.
Tim Ferriss: So to then take a look at how
seriously people in Hawai’i are taking this,
let's talk about the three-year hunt, and
we'll build from there.
Jake Muise: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: Actually, I'll just add one sidebar.
I'll put this in the show notes as well. For
people who are interested in learning more
about the incredible navigational skills that
you're referring to, there's a really beautifully
written, detailed chapter in a book called
The Wayfinders by Wade Davis that talks about
the sort of Polynesian diaspora and their
ability to navigate, and it is mind-blowing.
It's a real accident. It's a real mistake,
rather, to think of some of these ancient
technologies as primitive.
They're not always primitive. They're just
different sets of skills and technologies.
But they would have the captain as one person,
the head of the ship, just making everything
orchestrate. The navigator would be a separate
person, and they would basically sit like
a Zen monk and not sleep at all, because they're
tracking multiple currents. They're keeping
track of where the boat is in space, even
when it's totally overcast, and they can't
use the stars. I mean, it's unbelievable.
So I recommend people check out The Wayfinders
by Wade Davis.
Three-year hunt.
Jake Muise: Got it. So the Axis Institute,
which was what I started in college initially
as a means to collect information because
nobody in India would answer me. Then became
very much a way to learn more and facilitate
some research. Four axis deer were illegally
introduced to the Big Island of Hawai’i.
So we've talked about Molokaʻi, Lānaʻi,
and Maui. So four axis deer were illegally
introduced to the Big Island of Hawai’i,
which was just about 10 years ago.
The Big Island, it's called the Big Island
for a reason. All of the Hawaiian Islands
can fit inside the Big Island, and it is also
the food hub of Hawai’i. We grow all of
the vast majority of food on the Big Island,
and the impacts of axis here were already
really well known. So it was a state emergency,
when these animals were found, and the Axis
Deer Institute happened to be one of the few
people that knew a lot about axis deer. So
we were given that responsibility and contract
to try and find and remove four deer from
a hundred square mile area. So they didn't
know where they were. They —
Tim Ferriss: And these aren't elephants?
Jake Muise: Oh, no.
Tim Ferriss: What's the size profile? Just
so people can conjure an image.
Jake Muise: 150 pounds. Think about them standing
three and a half, four feet high, maybe six
feet long.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: So a pretty small height.
Tim Ferriss: So what are the biggest differences
for people who might be more familiar with
say, whitetail?
Jake Muise: Well, the biggest difference is
where they evolved. Axis deer evolved with
Bengal tigers and leopards in dense jungle,
and so they have this crazy sixth sense.
Tim Ferriss: Their agility is unbelievable,
and they're just vigilance, and sensory perception
is incredible to observe.
Jake Muise: I think because they didn't deal
with some of the evolutionary stresses of
seasons in India, they've also developed this
amazing ability to adapt their home ranges
to very safe areas. So on a typical home range,
could be a mile and a half to three miles
in a given day, but when they find a safe
spot, they will stay in a very small area
for an extended period of time.
Tim Ferriss: I see. So they move less than,
say, a whitetail, is that what you're saying?
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Therefore, they're better able
to denude a concentrated area.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So they'll find these little
cubby holes, these safe areas, and they'll
completely denude these areas and they move
onto these next places. But for the project
on the Big Island, which was literally a three-year
hunt, we worked every single day except Sunday
for three years to find these four animals.
Tim Ferriss: Did they multiply in the meantime
or no?
Jake Muise: Yeah, we ended up removing five,
but it was this extraordinary exercise. It
took us seven months. Like you think you go
on an average hunt, it's three or four days
and you're already tired. It took us seven
months to get a camera trap image of the first
one. We had 50-plus camera traps all over.
Every piece of water we could find in this
a hundred square mile area, we hiked every
day.
Tim Ferriss: Piece of water. You mean ponds
or lakes?
Jake Muise: Ponds, blue rock, that water would
pool in, anything we could find, water troughs.
Tim Ferriss: Any water sources.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So we finally get a camera
trap image. We're like, "Okay, we have idea
of [inaudible]." It takes us another four
months to get the first one.
Tim Ferriss: What do you do between? So you
set up the cameras, you're like, "We know
these things. We know that all animals..."
well, not all of them. "We know these animals
need water," and set up the traps and takes
seven months. So you get an image.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Boo, boo, boo, boo, boo. "Oh,
my God, we got our first image," and then
it takes another — how long?
Jake Muise: Three months.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. What are you doing in those
three months?
Jake Muise: So two things are happening. One,
we're doing ground transects looking for sign.
So you would love this. You're tracking every
single day. You're just looking for the tiniest
sign that they're in an area trying to —
Tim Ferriss: You used an expression “transect”
something or other —
Jake Muise: Transects.
Tim Ferriss: So you're basically breaking
it into grids so you know what you've covered
and not covered?
Jake Muise: Yeah. So you're gridding at — I
think we were doing 10 meters, massive areas.
But what we also did in the process, which
we'll move into our later story, is we had
to find a way to increase detection rates.
So we started, and it was such a huge emergency
that the military was involved as well. So
we got to work with the military and utilize
some of their forward-looking infrared, both
helicopter mounted and binoculars. The minute
we started using that tool, we knew instantly
like, "This is the tool that's going to be
able to find these animals."
Tim Ferriss: So forward-looking infrared,
FLIR?
Jake Muise: FLIR. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: FLIR is, can we think of this
as sort of black and white Predator vision
from the Schwarzenegger movie?
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Jake Muise: Exactly. You put the mud on you.
It's detecting heat and turning it into a
visual image for you to use. If you're cool
or not emitting heat, can't find you.
Tim Ferriss: I posted a video you sent me
of FLIR footage from a drone, which if you
want to see the scope, the magnitude of the
problem in terms of just the volume of animals
with respect to axis deer, you have to see
this video.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: It'll blow your mind. I put it
on Instagram, we'll link to that in the show
notes as well.
Jake Muise: Yeah. And we ran out of range.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah, exactly. It's not
like they stopped.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But it looks like a veritable
New York City of axis deer.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: At night.
Tim Ferriss: Unbelievable.
Jake Muise: So this particular technology,
which significantly increases detection rates
both from the ground but from a helicopter
platform as well, especially when looking
straight down, you don't have the vertical
layering of vegetation, you're able to look
straight down through vegetation and pick
up different heat signatures, that's actually
how we ended up finding them after the camera
trap image is we started flying on a constant
basis and then we figured out where they were,
took a week to put a plan together, and then
we were able to remove —
Tim Ferriss: When was this? What year was
this?
Jake Muise: 11 years ago.
Tim Ferriss: 11 years ago.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So were you using quadcopters
or a different type of drone?
Jake Muise: No, we were flying out of a helicopter.
Tim Ferriss: A helicopter. I was going to
say, this would have been very early days
—
Jake Muise: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Of any type of drone technology.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So we were out of a helicopter,
leaning out of the helicopter with a binocular.
Yeah, it was not a lot of fun. And we were
doing it four or five hours a day.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. That won't make you motion
sick or anything.
Jake Muise: Yeah. Yeah, well I've got lots
of those stories. Anyway, takes us another
two years essentially, but utilizing that
technology, we're able to find and remove
all of those deer including the two that had
been born. And there were very few invasive
species projects that are successful in Hawai’i,
period.
Really cool fact, introduction of species
to Hawai’i pre-human contact was every 25
to 50,000 years. It was whatever came through
wind or water, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: There is a new species being introduced
every eight days at this point.
Tim Ferriss: God, yeah.
Jake Muise: And again, the perfect place to
grow anything.
Tim Ferriss: So side note, and this might
be a total useless side alley that I'm taking
us down, why are there so many chickens in
—
Jake Muise: Oh, I love this story. Oh, okay,
here we go.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: They bring in mongoose, okay?
The powers that be decided we're going to
get rid of the rat population by bringing
in mongoose, one of their predators. Well
they didn't realize that mongoose are awake
during the day and rats are awake at night.
Tim Ferriss: Oops.
Jake Muise: Oops. Giant oops.
Tim Ferriss: And guess what? Mongoose are
really good at killing other things.
Jake Muise: So including our native birds,
which the introduction of some of these species
are so absurd. Anyway, so on the Big Island,
Maui, Moloka'i, I think — yeah, they have
mongoose and there's no chickens. Guess which
island doesn't have mongoose? Kaua'i.
Tim Ferriss: Why don't they have mongoose?
Jake Muise: They came to the dock, they were
introducing them to each island. They came
to the dock and somebody at the dock was smart
enough and he booted them off and drowned
them. He booted them off the dock and drowned
them.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: And it's just this amazing contrast
of you can't find a chicken on another island
on the side of the road and you can drive
on Kaua'i and see a thousand chickens in 30
minutes on the side of the road.
Tim Ferriss: So wild. I mean these highly
biodiverse isolated environments are so beautiful
and compelling and also so fragile to disruption.
True with New Zealand as well.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I mean in terms of biosecurity,
it is one of the highest priorities.
Jake Muise: Right. And they do an amazing
job. Hawai’i is doing better, but they've
done a very poor job over the years in restricting
what's coming into the island. So yeah, back
to that three-year hunt. So successful in
removing an invasive species that there could
have been a million-plus axis deer on the
Big Island. That's how large the Big Island
is. And would've been absolutely devastating
as we talked about before, food systems, watersheds,
nearshore fisheries, et cetera, et cetera.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: And then that was actually the
jumping off point for what is now Maui Nui
is some ranchers on Maui said, "Well, wait
a second, you guys actually did that?" And
you have this technology so what we also developed
with that third technology is highly accurate
surveys. So within 95 percent, we can tell
you exactly the number of deer that are there.
Tim Ferriss: And how do you do that?
Jake Muise: So transects again at 400 meters.
Tim Ferriss: And then you take a sample.
Jake Muise: No.
Tim Ferriss: You don't do a sample count,
because a lot of people do that, right, and
then they multiply it out.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So they do something called
distance sampling, which is they fly a certain
number of transects and then use math to basically
extend what they've found and make a guess
over a period. And so we do a complete transect
of the entire area at 400 meters with a 20
percent overlap so we can have a confidence
interval of the number of times we've detected
deer twice. And we have done several projects
where it's in a large, fenced area of a couple
thousand acres and we survey, we remove deer,
we survey again, and we're never off by more
than five percent.
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
Jake Muise: So we have a tool that can accurately
tell us the exact number of deer and the impact
of our management. And it's a tool, it's just
super important because otherwise I think
what we do would be irresponsible without
that level of data.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, without that level of precision.
Jake Muise: The folks on Maui said, "If you
can do that, come over here." And they were
still calling them spotted rats. That was
their relationship. They had been introduced
to Maui in 1959, in 1960, so they weren't
as culturally ingrained as they are on Moloka'i.
Tim Ferriss: And just to paint a picture for
folks, so the spotted, the axis deer, please
fact check the shit out of this if I get anything
wrong, but they're very streamlined animals.
They're not as beefy as whitetail. Their antlers
are angled more backwards. And they have,
I'd say just generally speaking, very tawny,
burnt orange color with white spots.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And that's hence the spotted
rats.
Jake Muise: Yeah. And that dappled coloring
was used in those jungle environments and
they camouflage between there and grassland,
it's amazing how well they'll move.
Tim Ferriss: Japanese deer are the same, it's
a very similar pattern. Yeah.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So it started the, "Oh,
wait a second, if you can be successful with
a project at that scale, what can you do over
here on Maui?" And that was actually the first
phone call to the USDA to say, "How do we
use these animals?" Because they were talking
about having us remove thousands and thousands
of animals and they didn't care what we did
with them. They knew there wasn't a solution.
We couldn't use them for food and we couldn't
donate them, they still needed to come under
some type of food safety inspection program
in order to donate them to food banks and
stuff. So that was the first call to the USDA
to say, "Well, wait a second, what would be
the process?" Because there were no rules
in place.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: What would be the process to —
Tim Ferriss: Well, it was just considered
off the table, right?
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So there are rules that just
never been applied to this type of harvesting.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So that three-year hunt
was the springboard into successful project
completion in that place where there's still
no deer and potentially had a massive impact.
And then the springboard to Maui to try and
do something more.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm going to do a little flashback,
Austin Powers-style or Wayne's World, maybe,
get my Mike Meyers stuff mixed up. Did you
learn about confidence intervals playing volleyball?
Jake Muise: I think actually no, it was in
the worst class of my life, which was business
statistics in college. But —
Tim Ferriss: Ended up being useful.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: You can't imagine how much of
that stuff actually comes back.
Jake Muise: Yeah. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So of course I'm teasing
a bit by bringing up the volleyball. Just
briefly so people have a little bit more color.
Jake Muise: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: Where does volleyball fit into
your life and where does free pizza fit into
your life?
Jake Muise: Okay. Was a classic Canadian kid,
played a lot of hockey until we were too broke
to play hockey anymore.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, how do you get too — okay,
too broke to play hockey, just too much gear?
Jake Muise: Yeah, too much gear, growing too
fast.
Tim Ferriss: Ah, right. I forgot about that.
Right, it would be replacing your ski equipment
every year or two.
Jake Muise: I remember my dad sitting down
and being like, "I know you love it, but you
need to pick a different sport."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: And they're like, "Volleyball
requires knee pads, that's all you need."
Tim Ferriss: Your knees shouldn't grow as
much.
Jake Muise: "Here's a great sport for you
to try."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: Ended up falling in love with
it, just an extraordinary sport, redirecting
balls, moving a hundred-plus miles an hour.
Luckily, got pretty good at it. Spent a lot
of time with our Canadian national teams in
different forms and then was recruited to
play at the University of Hawai’i. I was
a decent enough player. I actually think it
was — I sent them a video of surfing. We
started surfing on the east coast of Canada
when we moved out there. And there's six feet
of snow and a tiny little ice floating around
and they're like, "Well if this kid can do
this, he'll probably turn into a good player."
Played four or five years there where I became
a family member for that family on Moloka'i
where, we talked about earlier, was able to
travel because the east coast of Canada was
so far. Really lucky to play professional
volleyball for three years. Got to play throughout
Europe, the Maldives, Indonesia.
Tim Ferriss: So, pause, can you frame for
folks who don't have the context, a lot of
people, how popular is volleyball? It's not
something that people in the US generally
watch at all.
Jake Muise: Yeah. In Canada, there was nobody.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: It was my mom and dad cheering
us on.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: But Hawai’i happened to be — it's
the mecca of volleyball. They have a —
Tim Ferriss: Wait, worldwide or just in the
US?
Jake Muise: Oh, just in the US. They actually
won the last two national championships over
the last couple years, but they have a 20,000-seat
stadium that they filled on a regular basis
for men's volleyball.
Tim Ferriss: And then you go overseas to Europe.
Do people watch volleyball in Europe?
Jake Muise: Yeah, it's huge. So volleyball
is the second sport to football or soccer.
So you were associated with another club.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: And you just got basically spillover
of all the soccer fans or football fans. But
a huge professional league there that for
great players pays extraordinarily well. And
for me, which was not a great player, was
this amazing opportunity to go to Europe,
see all of these different places. And the
professional teams only ever accepted two
international players. So you were embedded
and immediately assimilated into whatever
culture you were in, which it's just such
an amazing way to be a part of those places
versus some outsider, right? So that leads
into the story of free pizza. So my first
week playing in Harlingen, which is in northern
Holland.
Tim Ferriss: Gesundheit!
Jake Muise: Yeah, yeah. Yeah, well that plays
into this story. I had a week of practice
and our first game was coming up and I was
still very much getting used to the language.
The coach was this 6'8 Olympic legend. He
was this legendary Dutch player. And I think
he was happy I was there, but I was just another
player. And you're paid to be there, so you
play really well.
Tim Ferriss: He's trying to mime with you
to get things done, right?
Jake Muise: He's not giving it a lot of effort.
And then we're playing one of the best teams
in the league for the very first game, we're
doing really well. He puts a play together
to finish the game. I had no idea what he
was saying, okay?
Tim Ferriss: What could go wrong?
Jake Muise: Completely screw it up, embarrassing
level screw up, and we lose. And after the
game, he comes aside in broken English and
he's just like, "You play better or we fire
you." You weren't playing for fun anymore
in college, you were getting paid to play
really well. And the reason I didn't play
well is because I couldn't understand what
he was saying.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: So the very next day we were reviewing
film and he was going off again and I didn't
understand what it was. And I just remember
putting my hand up and saying, "Does that
mean we get free pizza after the game?" And
he was like, "What?" And I was like, "Does
that mean we get free pizza after the game?"
He was like, "No, that's not what it means."
And then you could see his brain and he explained,
"No, we're going to be committing on this
individual." He explained it in English to
me.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: Half an hour goes by, he's getting
ready to tell us the bus schedule. It's all
in Dutch, I have no idea what's going on.
And I put my hand up and was like, "Does that
mean we get free pizza?" And he's getting
irritated and then I think it finally clicked
and he was like, "Wait a second, we need to
be a little bit more patient with this guy."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: And I tell it as a funny story
because I used that phrase as I went to Indonesia
and the Maldives and it was this amazing way
for me to ask dumb questions.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: Because otherwise I was lost.
And it has translated to one of — and I
know you've talked about this in the past,
it's translated to one of these small superpowers
that I have where I'm never afraid now to
ask the dumbest question in front of some
of the smartest people through that practice.
And it really is, it's a superpower.
Tim Ferriss: I want to highlight this because
it's really important, right? And I have another
friend, Mike Maples, Jr. And oftentimes when
he wants to ask a question that no one else
is going to ask but it's an important question,
but people are nervous to ask it for any number
of reasons, and he'll go something along these
lines. He's from Texas. And he'll be like,
"I'm just a country boy, I move a little slow.
So bear with me, let me ask you." And he's
actually razor sharp, right? But he has that
as a way to wrap a question that needs to
be asked in the same way that you were able
to buy yourself permission to ask these questions,
which by the way, a lot of the dumb questions
are on everyone else's mind, not in this particular
case with everyone else who speaks Dutch.
But there's so many circumstances where there's
some type of pink elephant question, but people
are nervous to ask it because they don't want
to look stupid or A, B, C, D, or E. But in
fact, it's a really important question.
Jake Muise: And when I was playing in Indonesia,
we had a Brazilian guy that spoke even less
English than me. And after my third day of
asking for free pizza, he came up to me and
he was like, "Thank you so much. I wouldn't
know what's going on unless you were asking
these questions."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: And now it just translates to
last week, we're building an API, which I
have no idea what the hell this thing — and
I just kept saying, "I have no idea what you're
talking about." And I had a clue, but I could
see the blank looks on the Zoom calls.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: Nobody knew what they were talking
about. And it just gets stuff done so much
faster.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: Yeah, and it's just been this
amazing thing in my life that has worked really,
really well.
Tim Ferriss: Just to put a bow on the chapter
of volleyball, so you mentioned that you were
not the Ronaldo of volleyball.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But you ended up taking an oblique
angle and extending your career related to
volleyball. How did you do that?
Jake Muise: Ended up starting or helping other
players find contracts. Yeah. So I had a couple
players that I knew that said, "You're not
that good. Just being honest here. You're
not that good, how did you get a contract
in Europe?" And I said, "Well I just called
everybody until they kept answering." And
was working with this other player agency.
Anyway, I found a great way to find mediocre
players, teams. And some of them were only
getting a thousand euros a month, but they
didn't care.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: It was the best thing ever, and
then got a small percentage of that salary.
And yeah, it was an amazing way to extend
that life and yeah, it was a lot of fun.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So let's come back to Maui
Nui. And there are a whole different number
of angles that I want to take to cover some
of what I think are interesting features of
things. And a lot of them tie into why Maui
Nui became my first ever, I mean really if
you look at my portfolio, food investment
in — when was it? 2019. So it was a while
ago. Part of it was I think there's a myopia
perhaps with many people who specialize in
some form of early-stage investing, let's
just say tech, to associate innovation purely
with technological advances in a certain medium
or in a certain capacity. But I saw a lot
that you guys were doing that reflected a
level of experimentation and unorthodox thinking
that was super attractive to me that made
me think it would be in combination with other
things like nutrient density, which we'll
talk about, attractive. And also, everything
is fucking delicious and I like delicious,
healthy things. Let's talk about the seven
on, seven off, because this will sound at
first description to be a little odd for a
lot of folks.
Jake Muise: Sure. So we have a very unique
schedule for our team members. And all of
our team members work seven days on, seven
days off. And they get a great compensation
package, great benefits. And it was originally
designed to deal with flipping back and forth
from the sleep schedule. All our harvesting
operates at night and we wanted to give our
harvesters enough space to essentially recover
and feel good and be able to come back to
work. And when we started to grow, we decided
to keep that system for essentially almost
all of our field and butcher staff, the vast
majority of who we are. And it's turned into
this extraordinary benefit that we didn't
see coming. And we did a little experiment
last year because we wanted to make sure we
were — living in Hawai’i's extraordinarily
expensive and we were trying to be as responsible
as possible. So we have two full teams, everybody
that works seven days on and another team
comes in, we essentially work nonstop. We
have two teams switching back and forth. So
we offered them unlimited overtime. And can
you guess what happened?
Tim Ferriss: Tell me.
Jake Muise: Nobody took it.
Tim Ferriss: So explain for a second what
that would actually mean. What is unlimited
overtime?
Jake Muise: Yeah. So we said on your seven
days off, you can come in and work every single
one of those days you work at time and a half,
at an overtime rate.
Tim Ferriss: And no one did it.
Jake Muise: Nobody did it. And it's just this
amazing mark —
Tim Ferriss: So what do you make of that?
Jake Muise: Time —
Tim Ferriss: They were just happy with —
Jake Muise: A, there's nothing more important
than time.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: B, lots of them, it's been this
really interesting and amazing thing to watch
them. Seven days is a long time.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: When we hire somebody, almost
inevitably their first week off, they call
me and they're like, "What am I supposed to
do? It's day four." And they're like, "I haven't
had a seven-day vacation in three years, what
am I supposed to do?" I'm like, "Well, get
used to it."
Tim Ferriss: Find some hobbies.
Jake Muise: Yeah. And it's been amazing to
watch them become a better community member
or start a food truck or start their own company
and they come back. We essentially have 100
percent retention of the people we want. And
they come back on the start of their seven
days and they are the most extraordinary person
coming back to us. And then they work amazingly
well for seven days. That age-old adage of
one person is better than two average is 100
percent true, and we have data to support
that in how we look at production and stuff
now.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: And so the other thing that I
think is really important for the people we
hire, which are hyper local people, we're
looking for people of those places, is you're
giving them an opportunity to leverage that
place and enjoy it. So half of them will just
fish for six days or go hunting or enjoy surfing
or something else. And it's just this amazing
schedule that really allows them to enjoy
the place that they are from and live in.
But more importantly, we have an extra extraordinary
group of people. And it just had to roll over
the hill a little bit and combine with the
other things like through COVID when nobody
could hire anybody, we had stacks and stacks
and stacks of resumes on my desk. It just
has turned into this amazing work environment
and we've had no lack of essentially efficiency
or production.
Tim Ferriss: So let's talk about some of the
processes and metrics that inform that output
and efficiency.
Jake Muise: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: Because it doesn't happen by
accident.
Jake Muise: No.
Tim Ferriss: And I've visited your operation
a few times now and I've always been, this
won't surprise anyone who's followed me for
a while, I'm always impressed with very finely
tuned tracking. So could you speak to some
of the metrics that you track and why they're
important?
Jake Muise: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: And then we'll segue from that
into let's have you describe what a shift
actually looks like.
Jake Muise: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: When you're going out at night.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So we have two —
Tim Ferriss: And you can feel free to switch
back and forth or do one first and then the
other afterwards.
Jake Muise: So the harvest side of what we
do, which is really the unique aspect of what
we've built, is these field harvesting systems
that comply fully with USDA standards, i.e.
everything that operates in a brick and mortar
we're able to do in the field through a combination
of forward-looking infrared and these different
software systems that we built. And we were
only able to create those systems and levels
of efficiency with what you're pointing to
is an absurd amount of data that we keep.
So we keep track of every mile, every bullet,
every time we stop, the moon phases, how the
moon phase influences deer, we call it moon-fluence.
And we have these giant KPIs and sheets that
basically —
Tim Ferriss: Key performance indicators.
Jake Muise: Yeah, that dictate where we go,
what we do and then who we put in different
places. Actually, I don't think I've told
you this, but we just submitted a grant to
NASA. Harvard and MIT, these PhDs at Harvard
and MIT found out about what we did, found
out we keep an absurd amount of data compared
to most agricultural companies and NASA has
a grant available for ag companies where they'll
fly this amazing satellite, comes over Hawai’i
at 10:14, we just finished putting this giant
grant together, crossing my fingers.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: And it's so detailed that these
amazing people at MIT and Harvard believe
they'll be able to detect deer with the satellite
and then use the information and data we collect
every single night on when we're seeing them
and how and how we're interacting with them
to incorporate with the machine learning to
create route planning for us. So they think
a combination of satellite data and the ground
data that we keep combined will be able to
tell us on the next day where to go.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Jake Muise: I was freaking out when they were
explaining all of this and lots of dumb questions
that went along with it, yeah. But they were
shocked at the amount of data we keep. And
they even got to see we've run lots of different
experiments of how we collect data. And I
think maybe what you're pointing to is just
this constant iteration of we're going to
try this thing, we're going to keep data.
I think there's that great saying, "Measure
what matters." If you don't measure it, you
won't know if it's actually worked and we
are just constantly changing and measuring
things. And so we've actually taken that philosophy
into our butcher facility, which is a very
well-known industry with well-known inputs
and production efficiencies. And we're crushing
those numbers and we're just doing it through
constant iteration. Doesn't matter if the
angle of a table or this machine or the different
knife that we use, we are constantly iterating
and constantly collecting data to see are
we producing a better product faster with
more quality?
Tim Ferriss: So let me come back to the USDA.
Jake Muise: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: Or maybe not directly USDA, but
comparables. And then we'll go from there
to a sample night, what the run of show looks
like in the process. And the reason I want
to talk about these two things is that in
the field, things are harder to control than
you would find in a facility where you're
using, say, cattle chutes and so on. What
does your, and people are not going to like
some of these words, so apologies to those
people, but I think it's fascinating and important
to cover these things, what does your, say,
kill efficiency or your measurements of humane
kill look like compared to a conventional
facility?
Jake Muise: Great question.
Tim Ferriss: And the reason I wanted to talk
about this, there are quite a few, but one
is that I know that a decent portion of your
customer base is vegans or vegetarians who
make a sole allowance for Maui Nui venison.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Which is maybe a head scratcher
for a lot of people. So let's talk about your
field efficiency compared to what most people
are indirectly experiencing when they buy
something just wrapped in styrofoam at their
local grocery store.
Jake Muise: Sure. Part of the systems we had
to build were we had to follow the Federal
Meat Inspection Act, which the USDA is present
to make sure that animal is supposed to be
harvested humanely and then that ultimately,
after that animal is processed, make sure
it's safe to eat. That's their two primary
functions. And I know this is hard for people
to hear, but if you eat meat like it's what
it is, in a typical brick and mortar facility,
that animal is coming in on a trailer moving
through a chute system going into a press
most often. So that animal is completely stationary
and then the language is called rendered,
but it's then essentially shot in the head.
So we had to follow those exact same rules
in the field and with no control of the animal.
Tim Ferriss: The rules meaning humane, safe
to eat.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But not following that process.
Jake Muise: But not following that process,
yeah. So we don't interact with these animals
at all prior to that rendering or harvesting
process. They're entirely wild. And what we
developed was a particular shooting system
that allows and/or standardized our shooters
to miss on purpose 30 percent of the time.
And that sounds weird, but what it is is we
are essentially making sure every shot that
we hit that animal is perfect and there's
never any outside injuries. And to do that,
if you shoot a two-inch group at 200 yards,
which is difficult to do, and you aim at the
very, very top or tip of a head, you are going
to miss about 30 percent of the time. And
so we actually operate —
Tim Ferriss: So just to —
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Paint a visual for people, so
two inches, it's a little bit bigger than,
say, a silver dollar.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So imagine you have something
that's slightly bigger than a silver dollar
and you put it 600 feet away, you need to
put every shot inside that silver dollar.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That's what we're talking about.
Jake Muise: Yeah. And then you need to make
sure your aim point is in a place that never
can create injury, because if you miss high,
nothing happens. That animal runs away.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: And so we actually operate at
about a 99.9 percent rendering efficiency.
Tim Ferriss: And what is the brick and mortar
average?
Jake Muise: 98 off of thousands and thousands
of animals. So we were able to meet and exceed
those guidelines or those rules.
Tim Ferriss: In the wild with animals moving
around.
Jake Muise: Yeah, with a combination of — so
you can imagine, and this maybe leads into
what a night in the field looks like, but
you have these Mad Max-looking UTVs with forward-looking
infrared screens essentially attached. The
USDA inspector is sitting right beside you
the entire time. And the technology is so
good that the heat, the friction the bullet
makes passing through the air, the USDA inspector's
actually able to see that bullet that took
the head of every single animal. And it's
just an extraordinary process where the animal
is unaware that you're there. And so it is
truly, truly wild until the second harvest
and then dies immediately.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: And so which comes into play for
nutrient density, there is no stress.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, they're not flooded with
—
Jake Muise: Prior to harvesting. And I think
when we get about a message a week from a
vegan that says, "I'm finally able to come
back to eating meat," because they understand
why the animal has to be managed and why that
animal's dying, and then they agree and connect
strongly with that process. It's truly the
only stress-free harvesting or slaughter of
an animal within our food system.
Tim Ferriss: Could you talk for a second about
why this is so rare, right? Because people
might think, "Well can't you just go hunting
and sell the meat?" You cannot do that.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So what makes you able to do
this?
Jake Muise: Yeah, great question.
Tim Ferriss: For people who don't have that
background.
Jake Muise: So an elk in Montana is a native
species and it is owned by the public. So
it's on public land. It's on public land.
Even on private land, that animal, the management
of that animal is dictated by the state. It
is still owned by the people, right? So an
invasive species on private land in Hawai’i
is the liability and ownership of the landowner.
So it is a very unique situation in which
you can actually do this process legally.
And it's only in the instance where it is
an invasive species on private land. We are
not allowed to operate on public land in Hawai’i.
Tim Ferriss: And I bring this up, I mean obviously,
look, I love Maui Nui. I'm an investor, so
of course I'm biased. But it all came down
to, and I think we were initially introduced
by Peter Attia.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: The quality, just this pure quality
and nutrient density of the product for me,
right? That's what it came down to. But I
think as means of just educating people about
game meat and the sale of game meat in general,
or let's just call it atypical proteins like
venison, elk, and so on. How much of the venison,
elk, et cetera, that people might buy at a
Whole Foods or something is farmed?
Jake Muise: 100 percent.
Tim Ferriss: 100 percent. So I bring this
up just to say that people say you are what
you eat. That is true, but you're also what
you eat ate. So if an animal, let's say deer
or an elk, is being fed, who knows, corn feed
and all sorts of stuff, and given antibiotics,
potentially, it's very different from something
that is wild-harvested. So I don't want to
skip too far ahead. Let's talk about a night
out, just what that looks like, and then we'll
talk about nutrient profile.
Jake Muise: You can imagine a bunch of hyper
local Hawaiians, who I love, getting up, rolling
out of bed. We all sleep on site. We've got
all these cubby holes for them to sleep in.
We all sleep on site. We're getting up, making
—
Tim Ferriss: 10:00 p.m.
Jake Muise: 10:00 p.m. Making dinner and breakfast
together. Some of them are diesel engines.
You've really got to shake them to get going.
And we are constantly moving, so we have mobile
facilities where we're moving from site to
site to do this process. We have these primary
sites on all of the different ranches that
we work with. So the first thing we're looking
at each evening is moving our mobile facilities
to another site to get closer to the deer.
And the reason is, one of the other rules
we have to follow is after that animal is
rendered, it has to be back to the facility,
cleaned, processed, without a single hair
on it, in an hour.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It's pretty mind-boggling.
So we'll also link to a video that shows snippets
of this that's on YouTube. Because if people
think about that, I mean, it's pretty mind-boggling
to think about it.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So we're asking our —
Tim Ferriss: And maybe you can walk through
how that's accomplished.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So we're asking our team
members to be snipers, rally car drivers,
CrossFit athletes, butchers. The people we
have on our teams just have these extraordinary
skill sets. It's the funnest thing to watch
a guy in his first week.
Tim Ferriss: Access to your decathletes.
Jake Muise: Yeah. We have to pick up every
single one of these animals and carry them
on our backs, because you're not allowed to
drag them. You can either introduce contaminants
and/or bruise the meat. And it's actually
one of my favorite parts of the night is it
is the complete opposite of the rest of the
meat industry. After you've killed this animal
for food, you're carrying this animal on your
back into its next stage of life with the
food. And there's an individual connection
with each one of these animals. And it's something
that every guy on our team really takes pride
in, is being able to pick up these giant,
250-pound animals across razor sharp lava
or all super —
Tim Ferriss: 250. That's a big boy.
Jake Muise: You have these giant bucks. Anyway,
we're moving mobile slaughter facilities and
we're getting all set up in stage and you've
got these Mad Max UTVs. And everything is
getting ready for what we call the performance
period. And the USDA shows up and it is essentially
game time. You have a finite period of time,
which for a long time was only three hours.
So you have all of the variability of a wild
animal and you have to make it all work in
a three-hour period. Your entire business
comes down to — your mission business, how
you operate, comes down to managing variances
in a three-hour period.
So nobody walks. Everybody drives faster than
they'd like to. And we've never had more than
a cut finger, knock on wood. And we expect
just extraordinary people and athletes to
come work with us. We have had lots of people
that have come and been with us for a week
and said, "I can't do this. I can't do this
every night. It's impossible." So USDA comes,
we have this very defined performance period
where we're going really, really fast under
control and getting as many animals as we
can, getting them back and processing them.
And then before you know it, the sun has come
up and the night is over.
Tim Ferriss: Now, just so we understand some
of the tools of the trade that go into this,
so you're using night vision scopes? How is
the technology layered to make this work?
Jake Muise: So the first piece of technology
that will start the night is these forward-looking
infrared drones. So a drone is going in there
to give us a picture of a couple thousand
acres to say deer are going to be in these
areas as we get started. The forward-looking
infrared binocular system that we use, I can
tell you the difference between a goat and
a deer at seven miles. So at 150 yards, you
can see every hair, any abscess. The USDA
being able to say that animal is healthy is
achieved through that technology. And there's
no lights on. It's completely black. Deer
has no idea what's going on as they're being
evaluated by the USDA. And then the shooters
also have forward-looking infrared scopes.
So you never have to introduce light into
the scenario to scare them. And that's what
allows you to harvest enough animals every
night to make it work. So you come up over
a hill, you see a couple deer, all of the
lights go off, all of this forward-looking
infrared equipment comes on instantly so the
USDA is able to view it.
He's able to look at those five animals and
say, "Yep, you're able to take those animals."
And we need to wait. He has to verbally say
those things. Oftentimes you can shoot several
of those animals because they don't actually
know what's going on. It's the middle of the
night. And the minute they don't feel safe,
they just run. So you know you're still harvesting
them under stress-free conditions if they're
just standing there. Half the time, they'll
go back to feeding. Animals are rendered properly,
they go down immediately. And as soon as our
shooter says "Clear," and the USDA says "Clear,"
people are sprinting into the bushes to find
these animals. Again, it's the middle of the
night. If the grass is four feet tall, we
have laser pointer systems that come off of
the UTVs to show them the right direction.
And animal gets picked up, brought back to
the UTV, and then we'll collect a couple of
them. We have a roving team, they're called.
So we have a team of rovers that essentially
are the Mad Max team, where they'll collect
a couple deer and then they'll move as fast
as they can back to where the mobile slaughter
and processing facilities are stationed. And
so they're just cycling back and forth between
the harvesting team and the processing teams.
So it's just this intricate dance. And this
is all at night on — this is not paved roads,
these are rough off-road scenarios. And so
one of my favorite things to do is the first
week we train somebody, we have a course that
they have to run. And we let them run the
course once, and it typically takes like seven
minutes. And we're like, "We need you to do
that in three minutes." And they're just like,
"What?" "We need you to do that in three minutes
or you're not going to get back in time."
And so it's always fun to sit in that seat.
And we have these very specialized UTVs that
are essentially impossible to tip over. But
it is so fun to watch these amazing local
guys develop all these incredible skill sets.
And every morning the sun comes up and everybody's
just grinning ear to ear. It very much feels
like a sports team. And obviously with my
history, I run it kind of like a sports team
and the coach. And just an amazing experience
to do one of these hunts.
Tim Ferriss: So just to define terms also,
if people don't know what UTV means, it's
kind of like a super tactical Mad Max golf
cart.
Jake Muise: There you go.
Tim Ferriss: That's a bit larger. Right?
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So people may have seen — Polaris
is one brand name, there are many others.
There are other terms used to refer to these
things, but that's what we're talking about.
So what are some of the other keys to selecting
or building a team like you have built? Because
you're asking a lot of these people. And it's
an unusual work culture. So what are some
of your frameworks, systems, criteria for
hiring, but also training once people are
in the position?
Jake Muise: I mean, great people already being
there to train great people really, really
goes a long way. And we can talk about that
system we built later, if you want, but the
communication and people being patient is
probably the most important thing. You have
to imagine, you're doing almost everything
through radios so you sound like Kermit the
Frog all night long. And you only catch half
of it sometimes, but you're moving really
fast and the expectation is you keep moving
fast. And so somebody has to be patient enough
when, "Oh, I didn't get that message," or,
"I didn't know what's it like." Communication
is so key when you can't see body language,
you can't hear properly. And everybody's operating
out of a headlamp, so you have this little
10-degree view of what you can see through
light. And I'm sure it's the most critical
thing in a lot of businesses, but when you're
operating like that at night, it just becomes
this amplified skill that if you don't have,
we get on it so fast.
Tim Ferriss: And communication, how do you
get on it?
Jake Muise: So early on, I've never had a
hard time talking, having hard conversations.
So I would talk to people about tone and approaches
and different words they could use, like reminder
instead of, "Get this thing done." We really
focused on individual language. And then we
basically built a language of harvesting.
So we have all of these key words. So we're
rolling, we have all these key words that
we use so people don't get confused with what's
going on. So we've created our own harvest
language that allows people not to get confused
when we're going really fast. And then ultimately
we built a system called HHS, which stands
for Humble, Hungry, Smart and is largely based
on —
Tim Ferriss: HPA. What was the first one?
Jake Muise: Humble, Hungry, Smart.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Gotcha. So [inaudible]
Canadian.
Jake Muise: Yeah. And it's largely based on
a book that Patrick Lencioni wrote called
The Ideal Team Player. And it is a peer-to-peer
evaluation system that measures humility,
work ethic and emotional intelligence. And
it became so important for us to have the
right people. The biggest risk we have every
single night is safety. And it became so critically
important to have the right people and the
right personalities that we had to build a
system to measure those personalities.
Tim Ferriss: And that's in the recruiting
vetting process?
Jake Muise: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: How do you measure those things?
Humility.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So we created essentially
a scorecard. It has six questions per category,
so six for humility, six for work ethic, six
for emotional intelligence. Questions like
do the energy they bring every night, is it
consistent, as in it positive? So we talk
about body language and emotional intelligence
and all these different things within these
questions. And I'm happy to provide this thing.
And we use it in three ways. We give it to
the person on the second interview when we're
hiring somebody. So we say, "Here's the HHS
system. This is the only thing you're accountable
to in your first month." And two things happen.
They read it and they go — or actually they
just don't call back.
And I've made a ton of hiring mistakes in
the past where you get past this honeymoon
phase and people turn into grouches and there's
people's personalities involved. And I remember
a guy that we were going to hire that was
a brilliant electrical engineer who wanted
to quit his job, come work with us, because
he heard about the seven and seven schedule
and thought it'd be the best thing ever. And
then he read it and he didn't call me back.
And I really wanted to hire him, and I called
him back and I said, "Any reason you didn't
call me back?" He's like, "I have terrible
body language and I'm not willing to quit
my job and take the chance within the first
month that I get fired for bad body language."
Because we score them. If you're an A, we
celebrate and figure out a way to reward you.
If you're a B, we find immediate improvements
that you need to make within some of these
categories. And if you are a C, we let you
go on the spot, no questions asked.
Tim Ferriss: And you set that expectation
up front.
Jake Muise: We set that in the interview.
They have to agree to this system coming in.
They're evaluated by their entire team, including
them doing a self eval, which is a part of
the overall score. They get to grade themselves.
Tim Ferriss: And the team, are they sent on
a test evening prior to hiring, or I guess
they just know that once they start going
out —
Jake Muise: Yeah. So we call them tryouts.
But when somebody comes to try out with us,
which means we give them a month, we hire
them on, but we call them a tryout. And at
the end of that tryout, though, which is typically
a one-month period, they get graded by their
entire team. And they know. It's this really
tense moment where —
Tim Ferriss: How many people are on a given
team?
Jake Muise: Eight to 10.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. Yeah.
Jake Muise: So it's a good average. So if
somebody —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, if somebody's got a bug
up their ass about somebody —
Jake Muise: It doesn't matter.
Tim Ferriss: It's just one person.
Jake Muise: It always ends up being a great
average and it always ends up being a great
measure of that person. And it's been this
extraordinary filter for hiring. Asshole is
the wrong word, but when we figured out how
to use that system, we now grade every person
at their first month. We grade every single
person quarterly, including me. Every single
person gets graded. And there's questions
on there like, "Do they try or ask to do more
than is required of them every day?" And it's
been so amazing to see the mistakes I make
in when we're hiring new people or moving
people around.
A great example is I moved a couple people
from a field position into a management position,
and then all of a sudden their work ethic
score started coming down. And it wasn't because
they weren't working any harder, it was I
didn't do a good job defining to the team
what their new responsibilities were. So they
saw them sitting on a computer and doing these
things, and they're like, "Well, they're not
in the field helping us." And so it's just
this amazing quarterly exercise that just
pulls out all of the tension within your teams
and creates framework for people to address
those tensions. And then ultimately what's
amazing is to watch people grow.
Tim Ferriss: How do you give feedback? Let's
say they come back and they've got a bunch
of Bs.
Jake Muise: Yep. So we —
Tim Ferriss: What's the big boss do?
Jake Muise: Yeah. So we sit them down and
we say —
Tim Ferriss: Is that the royal we or is it
just you?
Jake Muise: No, no.
Tim Ferriss: It's multiple people.
Jake Muise: Yeah, it's me and the two or three
other harvest managers. Great example. One
of the questions we ask talks about are they
genuinely happy to see their teammates succeeding?
Because safety is such an important part of
what we do, when we bring somebody in that's
more talented, just like a sports team, moves
the best people into the best positions, we
immediately move people around positions based
on their skillsets. So somebody has to be
genuinely happy to train somebody that may
replace them in a role that they may enjoy
more.
Tim Ferriss: They used to be the right striker
or whatever.
Jake Muise: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: And they just got replaced.
Jake Muise: And it's amazing to watch somebody
that really wants to be there because they
find purpose and they really love the schedule
and they know the impact that they're having
to our community have to make the decision
to be better for their teammate every night,
to be celebrating that person's growth, even
though it's potentially coming at the cost
of something that they enjoy. And so there's
these —
Tim Ferriss: That's hard.
Jake Muise: Oh.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, I'm not saying it's unreasonable,
but I mean, that's asking a lot of a lot of
people. I mean, I don't know if I would — if
I'm being honest with myself, I think that'd
be hard.
Jake Muise: Here's the thing. It's been such
a amazing exercise, with lots of iterations.
The first three iterations I made so many
grown men cry and I felt so bad.
Tim Ferriss: Was that your delivery or the
measurement? Were you just like, "Hey, listen,
fuckface?"
Jake Muise: It was just a mess. The measurement
was wrong.
Tim Ferriss: "You can sink or swim."
Jake Muise: No, you're getting evaluated by
your peers on your personality and the value
it's bringing to your team. And you have to
sit down quarterly and be told, "Your humility
is not good enough for this team."
Tim Ferriss: I assume that the responses are
all anonymized.
Jake Muise: Yeah, everything's anonymized
and then averaged.
Tim Ferriss: For what it's worth, I've done
what's called a 360 interview. And I know
people who as executives or founders have
had these done. And without exception, myself
included, every time that I spoke to somebody
who's experienced this for the first time,
they're like, "I went and then sat in my car
and I basically had a nervous breakdown crisis
of meaning. What do I do?" These are names
everybody would recognize, but they were just
like, "Holy shit."
Jake Muise: Yeah. The first time we did it
with a large enough team that I included myself
in it, because we were just so small early
on. It was I think the third iteration. I
was like, "I need to be a part of this." And
I got all of the feedback back. I was just
like, "Oh, my God." But if we really want
to build extraordinary teams, I realized my
approach to some of our conversations had
to be so much better and nuanced to make them
better. And it wasn't the right approach.
And you learn all of this. You end up reading
this thing like braille after doing it. I've
done it hundreds of times now.
Tim Ferriss: And with repetition, I imagine.
It's like exercise, right? It's like, okay,
if you're going to do apply metrics once a
year, you are going to be very, very, very
sore. And you might even hurt yourself. But
if you're doing it routinely it changes.
Jake Muise: But it was amazing to see what
happened. We built this system because we
knew we had to go from like eight people to
45 in a really short period of time to hit
our mission goals about a year and a half
ago. And I had made poor hiring decisions
in the past, and they were mostly personality-based,
or that person was operating amazing when
I was around, but the minute I left, they
turned into a different person. And then there's
this he said, she said game that this completely
erases all of that. Because it's anonymous
team scoring and the manager doesn't have
a unweighted vote whether that person stays
around. And what ended up happening is that
HHS program started attracting people. They
started hearing about this accountability
process to ensure —
Tim Ferriss: You're attracting better fits.
Jake Muise: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So you're not saying, "Hey, fuckface"
in the fourth, fifth, 10th, 20th iteration.
What's the language that you use if somebody
has growth opportunities, let's call them?
Jake Muise: Great. It's really specific to
which of the 24 or which of the 18 categories
they're struggling in.
Tim Ferriss: But how does the meeting start?
Jake Muise: Okay. So we sit down and we're
going to give them paper and we say, "Okay,
you're a B-minus."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. "Tim, we put a 250-pound
animal on your back. You crumpled into an
origami crane and you couldn't get up."
Jake Muise: So you're a B-minus. And then
we celebrate, first, some of the categories
that they're doing really well in. Some of
the categories that point to professionalism
or energy or all these different things we
celebrate right away because each one of the
24 segments have different scores within them
that have been averaged throughout their team.
And then we address the ones that they're
like a C in. And a great example, a lot of
our young guys that come on board.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. So they're not cut if
they have a C in a particular —
Jake Muise: A C average.
Tim Ferriss: — review point. It's the average.
Yeah. Got it.
Jake Muise: So the C average, and it's been
amazing to see that system work. I've let
go several people that were Cs that I would've
never let go — I wouldn't have known to
let them go. I wouldn't have known that that
was the impact they were having on the team
at large. It just would've never come out.
Tim Ferriss: And I would love to — you mentioned,
I think you offered to maybe share the questions.
Jake Muise: Oh, absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: So we'll put that in the show
notes as well, tim.blog/podcast, because I'm
incredibly curious to check it out myself.
At least at face value, it seems like a very
elegant solution to a lot of problems that
can seem like fragmented, separate problems
you have to address in different ways.
Jake Muise: And again, I'm just a system builder,
and by no means is it perfect, but I've heard
lots of people speak to how important these
different personality traits are and how they
reward them. And more importantly than the
C are the As. Being able to say to somebody,
"This incredible combination of humility,
work ethic, and emotional intelligence is
making your whole team better." And your whole
team is telling you you're extraordinary at
the thing. Being able to reward and compensate
somebody for that and have a measure to do
so.
Tim Ferriss: When you say compensate, so let's
say they have — I know this is getting in
the weeds a bit, but I feel like that's where
a lot of the good stuff is hiding. So how
many questions were there again?
Jake Muise: There's 18 questions. Six on humility,
six on work ethic, and six on emotional intelligence.
Tim Ferriss: And they get this A, B, or C
for each of those questions.
Jake Muise: Yeah. It's graded one through
seven. We just did it because there was seven
days of the week, and we talk about being
excellent every day. So it's one through seven.
And then we add of all the scores, which is
126 total, and they get a percentage. So if
they're an 87, we give them a B-plus.
Tim Ferriss: Which is the average or the total?
Jake Muise: Which is the average.
Tim Ferriss: How do you reward or compensate
the As?
Jake Muise: If they're in their first six
months of employment and they get two As or
A-pluses in a reward, we give them a raise
based on that contribution. And then we celebrate
with the team like "[inaudible name] was an
A this last quarter." And we make sure the
team knows the contribution that they're having.
And what's so interesting, they already all
know.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Right.
Jake Muise: But to not have framework to reward
them for being amazing people has always been
this fuzzy place for me where I couldn't reward
or compensate that person for being an extraordinary
individual that was making their whole team
better because it didn't fit into what the
classic hard skills define, as they're a great
shooter or they're a great driver or one of
these different things. And every single one
of those A-plus people are our most highly
skilled people as well. When you operate with
a certain level of humility, you are more
willing to learn. And you learn faster.
And every single person that's come through
our program that was a B-minus or a C that
was highly skilled had made the choice not
to get better at these, what I very much consider
skills, just weeded themself out. It's been
really cool to see people grow. And you're
in this camp and you see these guys. A lot
of them will tape their score up above their
bed. And they'll like look at it in the morning
and say, "Okay, my job is to make — I was
a B-minus on this thing. I need to bring more
consistent energy every night." We've got
guys that go up and down and up and down and
they're like, "Okay, I'm going to be trying
to be more consistent." They know what they're
working on.
Tim Ferriss: That's so cool. This gave me
a flashback, because when I was in high school,
and I wasn't particularly — just for whatever
reason, I mean, I trained my ass off, but
I was not the most gifted wrestler. But I
was pretty tough. And not 10 out of 10 tough,
but I ended up reading this book. It's, I'm
sure, dated in a million ways, but it was
called Mental Toughness Training for Sports.
And there was an assessment. And it was actually,
now that I think about it, pretty similar
to HHS.
And I gave the assessment to five or six people
and they did the assessment. And then I took
my score and that became my reminder. And
that is when, in a single season, I mean,
I went from kind of middle of the pack to
almost entirely undefeated until the very
end of the season. And it's not because I
was the most gifted, but it's in part due
to having a constant reminder that is not
from one person. You spot patterns and you're
like, "Okay, if it were just one person, I
could maybe dismiss it. But now I'm getting
this from multiple people I respect." And
it works, man. It really works.
Jake Muise: I think we're in a unique position
where —
Tim Ferriss: And you could do this, I'm just
thinking out loud, obviously. I was going
to say talking out loud, but that's a bit
redundant. "I'm just talking out loud here,
folks." But you could use this outside of
an employment context. You could take this
HHS and give it to five to 10 people you know
and just ask them to be honest. That's the
prereq. I'm not asking you to be nice, I'm
asking you to be accurate.
Jake Muise: And I want to give credit where
it's due. Patrick Lencioni is an amazing — the
book The Ideal Team Player, which is what
a lot of — the questions aren't based on
it, but this idea that — the original name,
humble, hungry, smart, is from that book.
And so when somebody comes in, they have to
read that book and it gives them the base
principles of what we're talking about. And
then we basically design the questions. And
it's been incredible. You get young 25-year-olds
that come in and their first couple of weeks
they're sitting in a meeting and they're hunched
over and they got their hood on.
And typically, that's a hard conversation
to have with somebody, to say, "I need you
to sit up, take your hood off, be an active
listener." Because it's an uncomfortable thing
to talk to somebody about their body language.
And you get to do that immediately because
the team has framework and language to say,
"Hey, listen, brother. In three weeks you're
going to get graded. One of those things is
body language. And if you just sit up in the
meeting, take your hood off, and make sure
you are looking at the person talking, you're
going to get a better score. We like you,
we want to keep you around." If you happen
to come in late —
Tim Ferriss: It's set up front. It's not impromptu,
improvised.
Jake Muise: It gives them the ability to have
hard conversations when somebody rolls in
a little bit late, which is already unacceptable.
But if they don't genuinely apologize, somebody
gets to come to them and say, "One of our
questions is about being genuine about your
apologies if you've made mistakes. And we're
allowed to make mistakes here and we make
a lot. But you come in and being like, 'Oh,
sorry guys.' Don't do that next time and it
will be better." So it's outside of me, it's
given everybody else framework to have uncomfortable
conversations and/or celebrate people.
Tim Ferriss: So The Ideal Team Player, Lencioni.
This is assigned reading?
Jake Muise: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: This is an assigned reading.
Do you have any other assigned reading?
Jake Muise: Not for field teams. We have them
focus on that one for sure. For some of our
other staff, we have Confessions of the Pricing
Man. Simon, I think is the last name.
Tim Ferriss: I've read that book.
Jake Muise: It's really good. Anybody that
deals with any type of product strategy, I
make sure they read that one.
Tim Ferriss: I haven't thought of that book
in a long time.
Jake Muise: Oh, it's so good.
Tim Ferriss: Confessions of the Pricing Man.
Jake Muise: And then The Road Less Stupid.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. I don't know this one.
Jake Muise: It is one of my favorite general
business books. And I'm drawing a blank on
the —
Tim Ferriss: It's okay. It's memorable.
Jake Muise: I've read a lot, actually. Chris
Ashenden recommended it to me.
Tim Ferriss: For those who don't know, Chris
Ashenden is the founder of AG1. Previously
Athletic Greens.
Jake Muise: Yeah. And he's been an amazing
guy whose always handed me homework. He's
an amazing —
Tim Ferriss: He's a great operator.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So again, I'm happy to share
all of the questions. And I think when people
see the questions, actually, they're tailored
to our teams, but it's actually pretty easy
to tailor those questions to your specific
work format. I haven't quite found a way to
move them into the virtual Zoom world because
a lot of them are so tactile in how people
work together in workflows. And there will
be several iterations, we just changed it
again. But in its current format and framework,
I think it could be valuable to people. I'm
happy to share that.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing. Yeah. We'll put it in
the show notes for folks to check out. I promised
it earlier, so I want to not be remiss and
come back to it as this conversational boomerang
returns to me. Nutrient density.
Jake Muise: Got it.
Tim Ferriss: How should we tackle this? Where
would you like to start?
Jake Muise: We could start at when —
Tim Ferriss: This is true for plants.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Also true for meat. Anything
you put in your mouth has a certain composition.
And just because it's called the same thing,
banana, banana, banana, green bean, green
bean, green bean, does not mean they are equal
in nutritional value.
Jake Muise: I think, and I'll start at maybe
the end, I think nutrient density, i.e., food
quality, and being able to measure that accurately
and someone be able to understand it in its
simplest form, i.e., on a label, is going
to completely change our food system and be
the lever for regenerative agriculture.
Tim Ferriss: Meaning having an indicator on
a label, some type of measurement. Just like
you look at calories, just like you look at
fill in the blank.
Jake Muise: If you walked into a store tomorrow
and you flipped it over and there was two
blueberries and one said 92 and one said 76,
and you knew that 92 meant that was that much
better for you, measuring thousands of biochemicals
that they now can through metabolomic testing,
you're going to buy the one. And what's so
amazing about the conversation of nutrient
density is that is nutrition of place. And
when you think of regenerative agriculture
practices, which is basically just layering
conservation practices, like we're taking
care of soil, we're taking care of water,
we're doing these different things.
Tim Ferriss: Which people have done for a
long time in certain cultures.
Jake Muise: And we got away for for a long
time and now we're coming back to it. And
if you knew the quality of your food, not
measured by the five metrics that are currently
available, but measured by the thousands of
biochemicals that we can now test for, both
good and bad. And there's billions of dollars
going into this. The Patagonia Provisions
were like, "This is coming for sure." And
what was really interesting for us is we got
to be one of the first people to be fully
tested. So about two years ago, we submitted
our bone broth to a typical USDA FSNS lab
to make our label. And I remember them, they
called me and they said, "Something's wrong
with these bones." And I was like, "We sent
you the bone broth that were made from regular
bones."
They had thought we had put some form of protein
powder or additional collagen in there because
it tested 33 percent higher in protein per
ounce than anything they'd ever seen. So they
had to retest it and it came out the exact
same way. And our mission was never nutrient
density, our mission was to balance populations.
And I always knew it was better for me because
that animal had a choice to eat. But when
we got that testing, we were like, "Wait a
second, what is going on here?" So we sent
more, we sent livers and hearts and different
cuts into a conventional lab for testing.
Sure enough, lab emails me in the middle of
it. I remember this one. They're like, "There's
something wrong with the hearts. They have
too much choline." I'm like, "There's nothing
wrong. We just sent you a heart" And we were
working with — did you introduce us to Anthony
Gustin? Who? We got to Anthony Gustin?
Tim Ferriss: I don't think so, but I do know.
I know who he is. Absolutely.
Jake Muise: Okay. So we were working with
—
Tim Ferriss: He's helped other people I know.
Jake Muise: We were trying to figure out and
compare after we got that information to a
typical comparison to beef. What he pointed
us to, which was crazy and scary, is the vast
majority of the USDA databases from the 1930s.
Tim Ferriss: I wonder if I made that intro.
It's possible.
Jake Muise: You've made a lot of them, my
friend.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's possible.
Jake Muise: I appreciate it. But what we found
out is that the nutritional comparison to
beef weren't even actually able to do it because
the data was so dated and you're able to be
off within 20 percent on a label, which is
a whole other story.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. People who are packaging
things have more wiggle room than a lot of
consumers realize.
Jake Muise: 20 percent wiggle room.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's wild.
Jake Muise: Up or down, whichever one favors
them.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jake Muise: Yeah. So Dr. Gustin introduced
us to somebody, Dr. van Vliet at Utah State
University, who has probably one of the most
advanced food labs in North America. And he
was doing the largest beef study ever done,
and the most in-depth, measuring a thousand-plus
biochemicals through disadvanced metabolomic
testing. We just happened to get tossed in
at the end of it. So there's 200-plus beef
—
Tim Ferriss: Little spritz of axis deer.
Jake Muise: There's 200-plus beef samples.
And then they threw us at the end and he thought
like, "Oh, this will be really cool to see
an animal that has a choice to what it eats."
What that might look like in what we understood
as a fairly fertile area, right? Okay. Comes
out, two to four X the phytochemicals, so
all of the good stuff from plants that gets
transferred into meat were two to four X.
Were eight to 64 X the omega-3s, so like DHA
was 20 times — it was just, every single
category was absurd. And then probably the
most exciting for me is they measured oxidative
stress. The stress in animal goes through
during that process, you can measure that
oxidative stress and its impact on — there's
a whole bunch of chemicals I still don't understand.
I'm not a nutritionist, but they were able
to measure the negative impacts of stress.
And of course ours was essentially zero and
the cattle, the beef stuff, was all over the
place. It was pretty scary. But what was most,
when I saw it, the most exciting thing, honestly,
wasn't Maui Nui. It was, A, this is nutrition
of place. This is a direct reflection of how
well and how fertile a place is because all
of that nutrient density is coming from the
plants that they're eating in, i.e., the soil
—
Tim Ferriss: The soil, exactly. And the water.
Jake Muise: Yeah. And the water moving through
the soil and instantly realized if every consumer
had this level of insight into the nutritional
quality of their food, it'll completely change
the way people look at that food system. And
then we got to —
Tim Ferriss: And then it'll change the entire
sort of supply chain production side.
Jake Muise: Well, it's not a race to the bottom
anymore of producing commodities, which is
the most you can at the cheapest price. I
mean, this is my favorite saying. Every time
Peter Attia says we're over-nourished, I'm
just like, "Yes." We're producing an absurd
amount of calories that aren't good for us.
It's coming and we're going to understand
the nutritional quality of our food and it
will be graded and easy to know. And that
will create these direct relationships with
these, what will probably be regenerative
agri-practices that are fostering the health
of these places. Then so when we dug even
further, we found out that the leeward slopes
of volcanic —
Tim Ferriss: What does leeward mean?
Jake Muise: It is the windward side of a slope.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Jake Muise: Yeah. Hawai’i Haleakalā has
a very particular soil called andisols, and
then there are three types of andisols. Andisols
are some of the most fertile soils in the
world. They hold water better and hold more
nutrients from those waters better. And then
of the three andisol soil types, we have one
called ustand, and it's the most fertile of
the three. So, the slopes we're harvesting
these deer on are actually, I think the ustands
make up 0.05 percent of the world's soils.
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
Jake Muise: We happened to be —
Tim Ferriss: Luck of the draw.
Jake Muise: Yeah. And that's the thing. Again,
this was never our mission. The mission was
just to balance populations, but we happened
to have one of the most virile animals in
the world that has a choice to eat exactly
what it wants, moving through the most fertile
slopes maybe on the planet. I think that's
what Dr. van Vliet got so excited about is
he now has a marker to say when there's an
extremely fertile place that's like for most
part well taken care of in a lot of the areas
because they're able to go to the very best
areas, this is what nutrient density could
look like. And it's, vitamin A was 800 times
in the liver versus some of these beef livers.
Tim Ferriss: To come back to one point, the
DHA, I don't know if there's EPA in axis deer.
I have no idea. I'm not a lipidologist, if
that's the right term.
Jake Muise: I think there is, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: On the omega-3, side is eating
axis deer in terms of levels of omega-3s,
I guess we'd have to think about the sort
of concentration per ounce, but is it comparable
to eating some types of fish or would it still
be significantly lower than fish?
Jake Muise: Well, we don't know the answer
to that yet because the study measured it
in comparison to beef.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, right. I see. So the percentages
and so on were benchmarked to beef.
Jake Muise: The new piece of equipment that
Dr. van Vliet has coming in will be able to
give us measures in milligrams, micrograms.
We'll know that in the near future here, and
this is what ultimately, there's several companies
working on this. Audacious is one of them,
this amazing company. They're going to be
able to measure these thousands of biochemicals
to the form that you need to turn them into
a label. But we know, to answer your question,
we know even in comparison to beef, it is
about halfway to salmon. So it's actually
a significant source of omega-3s that, for
some people that don't eat fish, it goes a
long way. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Little inside joke, because
before we pressed record, we were talking
about some very, very well known professional
sports teams who are using Maui Nui to feed
their players. And some of these players,
for whatever reason, just won't eat fish,
but they will eat Maui Nui.
Jake Muise: Well, and blood test every week,
these extraordinary athletes. And we've just
started working with a lot of these sports
nutritionists, and they're going to be able
to measure for us if it's having an impact
on these athletes.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's cool. That's so
cool.
Jake Muise: Just really, again, never part
of the mission for us, but an understanding
of place. And this is what gets cool. My wife's
so excited and she's like, this comes back
to that conversation of innovation is a culture.
Hawaiians were able to produce extraordinary
nutrient rich foods with finite resources
for a million people. And Hawai’i now imports
95 percent of its food and half of it's Twinkie-level
nutritional value. It really points back to,
I think our place is informing what we're
doing. And it's really fun to have such a
strong connection to place and it helped to
inform your solution.
Tim Ferriss: Connection to place, you have
Kuʻulani, you have the little ones. Oh, yeah.
Jake Muise: Right?
Tim Ferriss: You live in Hawai’i. Let's
talk about the family for a second. Uh, oh.
Clawback allowances.
Jake Muise: Man, I get to give you credit
for this.
Tim Ferriss: This is —
Jake Muise: Wait till you hear this one.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Okay. Fire away.
Jake Muise: John List.
Tim Ferriss: I was just thinking about John
List.
Jake Muise: John List, the economist you had
on the show, and he was talking about using
clawback allowances in a professional format,
but I remember him talking about using it
to potty-train his kids. And this idea of
loss aversion, like I already have it and
you're going to take it away from me being
much stronger than the opposite.
Tim Ferriss: Right. How hard will you work
to make $50 versus how hard will you work
if you feel like $50 has been taken away from
you?
Jake Muise: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: The latter.
Jake Muise: We had been struggling with —
Tim Ferriss: Equals a lot more.
Jake Muise: — allowances for the kids. And
we make lots of mistakes as parents. And what
the allowances were accidentally doing were
they were training them — they had jobs
and they did their jobs and then they earned
their money if they did their jobs. But what
it was doing is when we asked them to do extra
stuff and be helpful, it was like, "Well,
am I going to make more money?" And we had
taught them this system that was the opposite
of what we were trying to teach them, which
was to try and be helpful. And me and Ku'ula,
I remember her listening to it six hours later
than I did. And she's like, "Did you hear
about the clawback allowances? Did you hear
about clawback?"
I was like, "Yes." And we both thought of
it instantly. "Let's do it for allowances."
And so what we do now, and we changed two
things. We put $20 in ones on the fridge at
the beginning of the month and we say, "This
is yours. And what we do now is we claw back
those dollar bills for attitude instead of
jobs." What we do is when we say, "Palikū,
can you go feed the dogs?" And he's like,
"Ugh." We just walk to the fridge and we pull
off a dollar and it was this amazing exercise
over a period of three months to, it was straight
revolt, "What are you talking about?"
Tim Ferriss: Mutiny on the ship.
Jake Muise: And revolt turned into a little
bit of sarcasm. Like, "Yeah, fine. I'll do
that." Because they didn't want to lose their
money. One step back. We don't buy them anything.
We're kind of strict when it comes to, they
get stuff at birthdays and they get stuff
at Christmas, but other than that, they need
to be useful people and earn their money.
And so they really value the dollars they
get at the end of the month. And it went from
mutiny to sarcasm. I remember it happening,
and I remember asking Leiʻohu to grab the
laundry, and she's like, "Sure." And I was
like, "Wait a second." And I looked at Ku'ula,
I was like, "That actually just worked." Don't
get me wrong, don't get me wrong. They're
amazing kids. They're 99 percent of the time
—
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, but they're kids, they're
little humans.
Jake Muise: And now, just a couple weeks ago
I came home and Palikū was like, "Oh, I cleaned
the car." And I was like, "What? What's wrong
with you?" It was this odd thing that a combination
of the clawback allowance and training for
attitude instead of them earning for a task.
If it helps anybody, again, we're not amazing
parents by any means, but —
Tim Ferriss: I think you're pretty good parents,
from what I can tell.
Jake Muise: That small trick, oh, boy. It's
been a big one for us for sure.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to toggle around a
little bit here. I have some notes in front
of me. We're talking about the kids.
Jake Muise: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Secret Pinterest boards.
Jake Muise: Oh, man. This is another one.
Tim Ferriss: For the relationship between
you and your wife.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: All right. I know you're not
allowed to talk about it, but it's just me
and you.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Just us sitting at this table.
Jake Muise: Well, I've actually —
Tim Ferriss: Not millions of people.
Jake Muise: I've actually tried to talk about
this with a couple of our friends, and this
is Fight Club level, "You don't talk about
this."
Tim Ferriss: Exclusive here first, folks,
Tim Ferriss Show.
Jake Muise: All of the credit, much of my
credit goes to my amazing wife, but all of
the credit for this one goes to her. And there's
like, this has to happen in a very, you have
to follow the rules of this one or it doesn't
work. Early on in our relationship, I think
I'm two years in, she's an extraordinary person,
have no idea what to buy for her. I've failed
several, several times, and she's not like,
this is not — she barely will spend a hundred
dollars on herself a couple times a year.
She's that type of person. She thrifts 99
percent of her clothes, et cetera, et cetera.
So it's just the worst person ever to try
and buy stuff for. She's so picky.
And she sits me down, I give her a birthday
gift, I get it all wrong. She sits me down
the next day and she's like, "This is what
we're going to do. A, we're never going to
talk about this conversation again. And B,
I've created a secret Pinterest board that
I've invited you to. Every item on there is
something that I want. It's exactly what I
want. The link goes exactly to it. But here's
how this works. You are never allowed to talk
about this, and you're never allowed to give
it to me for a birthday or something." And
we're not big on birthdays anyways. And she's
like, "I will pretend that you did it in every
single instance." No, this is the most important
part, okay?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Right.
Jake Muise: My children think I'm a genius.
They'll come home and they'll just be like
this random box on the table that has these
beautiful earrings in them and Kuʻula will
come in and she'll just be like, "Oh, my God.
How did you know? This is exactly what I wanted.
I can't believe you found them. I've been
looking for them forever." And my girls will
look at me like, "That's amazing, dad. How
did you know?" She does it so well, half the
time I think, "Oh, my God. I'm amazing." She
has fake cried several times. She does it
in front of her mom.
The only way this works is I believe half
the time that I've done this amazing thing
for her. That's how important it is. And it
has been the greatest. I never ever think
about buying her anything. Anytime I even
have the slightest inclination, I go straight
to the Pinterest board and I just grab one
thing off of it and it shows up. And she does
this amazing job of, "It's the biggest deal.
Your dad's the most amazing person for be
able to figure this thing out." And they all
believe it. And we're never allowed to tell
anybody about it.
Tim Ferriss: What a great secret.
Jake Muise: Oh, it is so — she's done it
in front of couples and the guys are just,
"How the hell, how did you know?" I'm like,
"I just pay attention, man. I just figure
it out." She just makes me look so good. And
she gets exactly what she wants. I tried to
bring it up once when her mom was around and
she looked at me like she was going to kill
me. She's just like, "We don't talk about
it or else it goes away and it doesn't work."
Tim Ferriss: You know the rules.
Jake Muise: Oh, man.
Tim Ferriss: Bite your tongue.
Jake Muise: It's so good. It is. She has to
pretend it's real, and I feel amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Win, win. Oh, win, win, win,
win, win, win, on so many levels. All right.
I'm going to let you choose where we go next.
Jake Muise: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: Old lady crying on the couch
game, or tug of war?
Jake Muise: Okay. I'm going to stick with
my wife's a genius one here, and we'll give
her the old lady on the couch game. She, for
years — and I didn't ask about it until
recently. She, for years, has done this thing
and I didn't know what it was. And when she
was frustrated or something was going on,
she would close her eyes and instantly turn
into the happiest person in the world and
be loving our kids, even if they were monsters.
And I didn't know what was happening. And
so I finally asked her, I was like, "Okay,
what is that thing you're doing?"
And she's like, "That's my old lady crying
on the couch game." And I'm like, "What is
that?" And she said, "When I'm feeling frustrated
with my kids, I pretend I'm 80 years old."
And she's amazing. She really closes her eyes
and she pretends she's 80 years old and she
says, "I'm given the opportunity, it's my
birthday, or it's something, and I'm given
the opportunity to use a time machine, but
I am only allowed to go back to this exact
moment." And she really does it. She closes
her eyes and she opens her eyes and she's
80 and she has five minutes to be this 80-year-old
lady looking at her nine-year-old daughter
again after she's been grown up. And she can
open her eyes and she just stands up and she's
like, "Oh, she's so cute." And she kisses
their face and the kids know what the game
is. And they're just like, "Oh, Mom. You're
doing that thing again."
But she genuinely can put herself in the place
of gratitude to be back in that moment, seeing
her kids again after 30 or 40 years of them
being grown and old. And it's just watching
her do it is amazing. And then I have tried
it several times since she told me. If you
really put yourself in that situation, I've
done it with my son. He's turning 14 and he's
got hair under his arm. It's happening, puberty's
happening, it's happening. And I only have
four more years with him until he graduates.
And a couple times I found myself frustrated
with him. I close my eyes and I think when
I'm 80 and my knees are sore, what would I
feel to be able to go back and see him at
14 when he's in this place?
Tim Ferriss: Your self-care at 80 is amazing.
If you're just like, "When I'm 80 and my knees
start hurting," but yeah, I get it.
Jake Muise: Well, no. I've got big plans,
and I've got Peter Attia as my friend. But
it's this, she's a genius. In some of the
most frustrating moments where you've like
— kids are your greatest joy and they will
frustrate you more than anybody on the planet
can. And she's just found this way to have
gratitude for that time because it's gone.
And she calls it old lady crying on the couch
game because she cries. She'll be tearing
up and the kids will be like, "Oh, God. Here
we go again." Because they get kissed all
over the face and, "Oh, you're so small and
cute and it's amazing." And yeah, she's amazing
at finding ways to be grateful for sure.
Tim Ferriss: This, I'm really grateful you
brought this up 'cause it reminded me of something
that I found super valuable for a couple of
years, and then as often happens, I just kind
of forgot about it, which was for Tribe of
Mentors, so my last book, there were many
people featured and one of the questions I
asked almost everybody was, "When you were
feeling overwhelmed or frustrated, what do
you do?"
And one of the answers was, "When I'm feeling
overwhelmed or frustrated, I look at whatever
this mundane situation is," and I'll give
a personal example. If I'm laying in a hammock,
and not necessarily — I could be frustrated
or preoccupied by something, but my dog Molly's
playing with a stick and I'm just kind of
chilling. I ask myself, "50 years from now,
how much would I pay to come back to this
moment for just 10 minutes?" Similar trick,
right?
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But I haven't used it.
Jake Muise: It's so good, man.
Tim Ferriss: And this is the perfect reboot.
So, thank you, Ku'u.
Jake Muise: Oh, yeah. Again, she gets the
vast majority of the credit for anything that's
smart that comes out of my mouth.
Tim Ferriss: Tug of war.
Jake Muise: Okay, this one, Ric Elias, founder
of Red Ventures, introduced to me through
Peter gets all of the credit, but it was so
good. I just, it's something that I started
doing that I have to share. And he described
— this is the last parenting one, I promise.
He described parenting as a tug of war you
have to lose.
Tim Ferriss: Okay?
Jake Muise: It's really interesting when you
have kids and you hold onto them. I've heard
lots of different parenting advice, and the
reason it stuck with me so well is it's such
a great visual of your kids pulling a line
across from you and that line moving through
your hands. When they're two and three years
old, you don't even have to hold it. You're
just like, "Whatever. You can't pull that
thing." And then they get six or seven and
they give it a little tug and you're like,
"Oh, well, I've got to hold onto this thing."
And then the best part about that advice is
knowing you have to lose. So knowing when
they're 18 or 19, you have to have fully let
go of that rope. The visual that comes to
my mind all the time is just this really slow,
steady release of that rope instead of these
giant jumps or these parenting mistakes that
you're not letting them become independent
and responsible and useful. You're trying
to teach them all of these things so that
you can let go of the rope at the end of it,
and they're okay. You're trying to spare them
the feeling of being useless.
Tim Ferriss: How does that impact that metaphor
or analogy? How did that affect how you parent
or make decisions?
Jake Muise: Good example. Leiʻohu asked for
her first sleepover, which we've been pretty
stringent about because she wants to go an
hour away and sleep in a house. My immediate
reaction was, "No." And then the thought in
my head was like, "Wait a second, she's 12,
and if you're going to let go of the rope
a little bit, you're going to have to let
it all the way go. This is probably the right
situation to let it go a little bit." Make
sure it's safe and you call the parents and
you figure out what it is. But it reminds
me, the best actionable use of it is knowing
you have to let it go, knowing it has to be
gone.
Tim Ferriss: You have to do it eventually,
so do you want to let go of 20 feet at once?
Probably not.
Jake Muise: Yeah. And they fall flat on their
ass. Or do you want to gradually let it go,
so it's okay? And just the idea of seeing
it moving through your hands and knowing you
don't want it to be this sudden jerk has made
it easier for me to make those small decisions
knowing at 18, 19, hopefully, we'll see they're
gone, right? And they'll always be mine, or
ours, but it's one of the few parenting advice
I've ever heard that made me, that created
an actionable thing where I said, "Okay, I
need to make this slow and smooth and the
right transition for them." So thank you,
Ric. It was a good one.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing. I want to ask just as
we start coming to a close, a few questions.
One is, what are your hopes and dreams for
the next few years? I want you to also answer
something, which is one of the questions,
you may not remember this, but it was a very
important question for me to ask very early
on, which was I asked something along the
lines of how do you ensure that you do not
overharvest or end up doing more damage than
good? Because people respond to incentives.
If this economic model works, if the product
is very, very high quality, which it is, if
there is a lot of demand, how do you ensure
that you're not seduced by the sirens of capitalism
and end up becoming something antithetical
to your current ethos? So maybe that ties
in just in terms of rules, objectives that
you've set for yourselves as a company, but
broadly speaking, also hopes and goals over
the next few years.
Jake Muise: Okay. I'll answer the second first
in that our mission is to achieve balance
and defining balance, we don't actually get
to do that, which is probably really important.
We have the tools to make sure we can measure,
like we talked about during surveys, we have
the tools to make sure we measure really accurately
how many we're harvesting and the impact it's
having. But the individual landowners ultimately
make that decision. And then the community
at large gets to weigh in as well through
public lands.
If we've done our job really well, deer will
find a place within our food systems, not
within our critical ecosystems that collect
water and not at densities that impact our
reefs. They will find a way into our food
systems in these mid-elevations. And the ranches
are already pointing to that. They get to
decide what densities they want, and they
can only have densities that are healthy,
i.e., they grow enough grass that those animals
are healthy and sustainable. So we get to
be the tool to help find balance. We actually
don't get to answer the question, which is
the guarding agent between us doing more harm
than good. They get to make that decision,
which is awesome. The community gets to make
that decision.
And there'll be some ranchers that decide
— ranchers are grass farmers, right? There'll
be some ranchers that decide, "I'm not doing
cattle anymore, I want more deer in this area."
But we have the tool to manage them the same
way they would a cattle herd. And that's really
my hope for what we're doing at Maui Nui is,
we find the balance that's best for all of
our communities: ecosystem communities, food
system communities, our human communities,
nearshore fisheries. And the great part about
what we've talked about today is where there's
just so much iteration to what we do, and
it's so variable that it's the infinite game
for us. That we're just going to keep doing
it every single year trying to find balance.
Because some years you'll have more rain,
some years you won't, and we'll constantly
be able to go back to our community and say,
"How is this working? What does this look
like?"
And I think maybe balance is maybe my hope
for life as a whole and personal goals. I
don't have, this is not a multi-billion dollar
business for us. I'm so content. We already
love the place that we're in. I don't need
bigger, brighter, shinier things. If I've
done a great job letting go of that rope really
slowly and collectively, like we've talked
about today, growing incredible people. I
never realized how much value I'd find in
growing teams. I didn't know I was going to
come back to that like I did with sports and
seeing the extraordinary group of people that
are now at Maui Nui and being the shield that
ensures there's only ever great people there,
ourselves included in that process, man, that
is hope enough and mission enough. If I can
do those two things really well, that'll be
more than enough. I think that'll go a long
way in serving community and hopefully my
kids and —
Tim Ferriss: The whole shebang.
Jake Muise: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Dig it. Last question is the
billboard question. This is sometimes a dead
end, so I'll take the blame if it goes sideways,
but if it goes well, I'll give you all the
credit. Simple question. There is a billboard,
metaphorically speaking. You can get a message
out to hundreds of millions, billions of people.
Could be an image, could be a quote, could
be a word, could be a question, could be anything.
Could also be something you want to remind
yourself of. Could be any of those things.
What might you put on that billboard?
Jake Muise: I remember thinking about this,
listening to your podcast for years, and it
may not make perfect sense when you read it,
but the first business book I ever read was
called The Little Red Book of Selling. It
was this tiny little thing that I got.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I know the book.
Jake Muise: And a quote in there stuck with
me for years, and it was, "Pick up the phone."
And early in my career that meant pick up
the phone, take any opportunity, do everything,
just always, always pick up the phone. And
later, as I've grown, it's turned into less
of "Pick up the phone and take those opportunities,"
but "Address the thing that is in front of
you that you don't want to. Have the uncomfortable
conversation, pick up the phone, just do it."
And what it's resulted in is a very rapid
iteration of taking action constantly and
not being a lot of downtime in between it.
And now it means today just addressing all
of those hard things that are in front of
growth or with my family.
And it's just been like, so if that billboard
said, "Pick up the phone," that could mean
something to somebody really different. Maybe
that's your mom that's calling that you don't
want to pick up the phone. But for me, it
has constantly iterated and it's been this
crazy thing that has stuck with me for — I
mean, I read that book 20 years ago and it's
just this thing that plays in my head all
the time. When I see something that I don't
want to do or I know that has to get done
immediately I say, "Pick up the phone." And
I just like, I'm able to just do it immediately.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: "Pick up the phone." Good reminder.
What a good reminder. Jake Muise. Français.
So nice to see you, man.
Jake Muise: Always so good to see you, my
friend.
Tim Ferriss: And people can check out Maui
Nui at mauinuivenison.com on all the socials,
at Maui Nui Venison. I love this company.
I love the ethos. I love your family. I love
the impact that it's having. And this is not
because we're meeting today, but if you look
at my backpack right now, I have three of
the — what's the right way to describe them?
Peppered sticks.
Jake Muise: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Is that fair enough?
Jake Muise: Yeah. Peppered sticks.
Tim Ferriss: The peppered sticks, which are,
I guess now I know what 10 to 11 grams of
protein per stick, something like that. If
I need to be on the run and I need some quick
pick-me-up for breakfast or snack or quick
lunch, just 30 grams-ish of protein. I just
throw three of those in. And a lot of my protein
for the last several years has been Maui Nui.
And I feel good about it. I feel really good
about it, and I feel good overall. So what
an adventure.
Jake Muise: Well, can't tell you how much
we've appreciated the support and insight
and advice. It's been highly impactful as
well.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. What a gift it's been to
get to know you and to realize, like you said,
well, I mean, your family's very down-to-earth,
but connected with the Earth in a way that
is very aspirational for me. I really think
very fondly, I still have photos on my phone,
of just us sitting around a fire and whether
it's having a fire at night and just decompressing
or having the most delicious/shitty instant
coffee in the morning, which is just fantastic
though.
Jake Muise: It is when you're out there.
Tim Ferriss: It really makes a difference
when you get up at five in the morning and
it's just fucking — you've been freezing
your nuts off, which surprise, surprise, can
happen in Hawai’i at elevation. And you
have that coffee and you're with people you
really care about and you feel close to. It
puts in stark relief how much nonsense and
garbage we fill our lives with when, in fact,
when you just sit with close bonds in close
proximity and connection to nature, how much
something very deep is nourished, that alleviates
much of the hunger for a lot of these trappings.
Jake Muise: A true connection to place, whether
personally or professionally, can essentially
solve for anything.
Tim Ferriss: Connection to place. Jake Muise,
so great to see you, man. Thank you for being
here.
Jake Muise: Thank you so much, my friend.
Tim Ferriss: And to everybody listening, we
will link to all sorts of stuff. All the books,
HHS, video clips, everything you can imagine
that we've covered in this conversation. Probably
not the secret Pinterest board. You have to
make that for yourself. We'll put those in
the show notes at tim.blog/podcast. You can
just search Jake and it will pop right up.
As always, my recommendation is be just a
little bit kinder than is necessary, not only
to others, but to yourself. And till next
time, thanks for tuning in. Mahalo nui.